EVERYBODY AND THANK YOU ALL FOR
YOUR INTEREST AND PARTICIPATION
IN THIS HEARING OF THE SENATE
AND ASSEMBLY OF VETERAN AFFAIRS
COMMITTEES ON THE MASTER PLAN.
FOR THE CALIFORNIA VETERANS
HOMES THE REQUIREMENT TO
PUBLISH A MASTER PLAN FOR THE
HOMES BOTH THE AS A SYSTEM IN
INDIVIDUALLY WAS IMPOSED A FEW
YEARS AGO BY THE LEGISLATURE.
IT WAS AFTER WHAT I THINK IS
FAIR TO SAY A DIFFICULT FEW
YEARS FOR THE HOMES THE PAST
FEW YEARS UNDERSECRETARY ABBAS
YANNI SEEN SOME IMPROVED TURN
IS IT AT THE- AND- WHICH IS
STILL UNDER WAY. THE AUDIT
REQUESTED. BY ME LAST YEAR SHED
NEW LIGHT ON WAYS IN WHICH
MANAGEMENT OF THE HOMES- HAD
MANY YEARS AGO BEGAN TO STRAY
FROM ITS ORIGINAL- MISSION
SERVING A VETERAN RESIDENTS.
ABOUT WITH STRONG LEADERSHIP
FROM THE SECRETARY IN SUPPORT
HERE IN THE LEGISLATURE WE HAVE
MADE SUBSTANTIAL PROGRESS IN RE
CENTERING VETERANS AND THEIR
NEEDS- AT THE CENTER OF HOMES
THE HOMES OPERATIONS. AFTER
NEARLY TWO YEARS THE MASTER
PLAN HAS BEEN RELEASED AND NOW
WE HAVE A PICTURE OF ONE OF A
POSSIBLE FUTURE A PICTURE OF
ONE POSSIBLE FUTURE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA VETERAN HOMES.
BEFORE WE BEGIN SCRUTINIZING
THE PLANS DETAILS I WOULD LIKE
TO THANK THE SECRETARY AND HIS
STAFF A CAL THAT WHO HAVE
DEVOTED SO MUCH TIME AND EFFORT
TOWARD. COMPLETING THE PLAN WE
APPRECIATE YOUR HARD WORK. AND
I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
TOGETHER TO FURTHER THE SHAPE
OF- THE FUTURE OF HOMES.
BECAUSE THE PLAN AS WELL
GROUNDED IN PREVIOUS WORK BY
THE LITTLE HOOVER COMMITTEE AND
THE LEG. ANALYST'S OFFICE AMONG
OTHERS THERE IS NOTHING AMONG
ITS RECORD. THAT IS TO
SURPRISING. BUT WAS HAVE EXTRA.
I'M AND I SURE PER BAG WILL
HAVE MORE TO SAY. WITH THAT I
WOULD LIKE TO MY COLLEAGUE
CENTER ARCH FOR A TO A JOINT
HEARING OF OUR COMMITTEES AND
SENATOR WOULD YOU LIKE TO. MAKE
SOME REMARKS THANK YOU SO MUCH.
I THANK YOU SEVEN MEMBER ONE.
GOOD AFTERNOON LADIES AND
GENTLEMAN AND TO OUR VETERANS
WELCOME. I THANK YOU- ALL FOR
BEING HERE TODAY IT'S A VERY
SPECIAL DAY FOR US WE'VE BEEN
WAITING. TO HEAR FROM THE
SECRETARY AND THE STAFF AND SO
THE DAY HAS ARRIVED I WOULD
LIKE TO AGAIN CONGRATULATE.
JOHNNY ON HIS REAPPOINTMENT- AS
SECRETARY OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF VETERANS AFFAIRS
REGULATION. IF YOU'RE SECRETARY
I KNOW THAT WE'VE ALL BEEN
WAITING. THE NEEDLES TO SEE HOW
THAT WAS GOING TO COME DOWN AND
I'M SO. GLAD THAT THE GOVERNOR
REAPPOINTED YOU AND I- CALLED
YOU PERSONALLY TO TELL YOU
THAT- WAS ROOTING FOR YET SO-
THANK YOU FOR BEING THERE. AND
THE SECRETARIES OVERSIGHT OF
THE EIGHT BETTER IN HOMES AND
YOU GOT TO FILL. BARSTOW TO THE
BEST A LANCASTER VENTURA WEST
LOS ANGELES FRESNO AND READY.
WHICH HOUSES OVER TWO THOUSAND
AGENTS DISABLED VETERANS IS
VITAL TO THE NEARLY ONE POINT
SIX MILLION VETERANS AND THEIR
FAMILIES HERE IN THE- AGAIN THE
COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AT ALSO LIKE TO
THANK YOU MISTER SECRETARY AND
ESPECIALLY YOUR STAFF. AT CAL
BET FOR THEIR TIME AND ENERGY
IN DEVELOPING THE MASTER PLAN.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMITMENT
TO VETERANS. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
HARD WORK AND BELIEVE ME IT
DOES NOT GO UNNOTICED. WE IN
THE VETERANS COMMUNITY
APPRECIATE YOUR SERVICE AS A
VETERAN AND AS SECRETARY. I
KNOW THEY'VE BEEN SEVERAL
CONCERNS REGARDING THE HOMES
OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS. BUT
THERE'S BEEN A GREAT PROGRESS
EVER SINCE YOU'VE COME ABOARD
AND IT'S BEEN RECOGNIZED. I
LOOK FORWARD TO AN ENLIGHTENING
DISCUSSION ON THE USES OF THE
HOMES LESSONS LEARNED AND HOW
WE CAN ALL WORK TOGETHER TO
BEST REPRESENT OUR VETERANS
ACROSS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
ALTHOUGH THE POPULATION OF
VETERANS OF THE WHOLE MAY BE
DECREASING. AND IT WILL
DECREASE OVER THE NEXT SEVERAL
YEARS. NUMBER OF DISABLED
VETERANS AS YOU KNOW WILL
INCREASE. I'M GLAD TO SEE THAT
THE DEPARTMENT FOCUSES ON THE
CHANGING NEEDS OF VETERANS.
ESPECIALLY THOSE WITH LONG TERM
PHYSICAL AND MENTAL HEALTH
DISABILITIES. ARE NEED TO
PROVIDE SERVICE NEVER STOPS WE
TOOK AN OATH. AS ELECTED
OFFICIALS YOURSELF YOUR STAFF.
AND THOSE THAT ARE HERE TO
SERVE IT NOT ONLY ARE
CONSTITUENTS BUT TO SERVE THE
VETERANS. AS BEST WE CAN. AND
ALWAYS REMEMBER THAT WE MUST
THANK THEM FOR THEIR SERVICE
CONSTANTLY BECAUSE THEY ARE.
THE I'D LIKE TO THINK THE HEART
OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA
AND I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SERVICE ONCE AGAIN AND YOUR
STAFF. ASSEMBLY MEMBER THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
SENATOR ARCHER LOTTO AND- WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO- PANELS THIS
AFTERNOON AND I WOULD LIKE TO
BEGIN WITH- THE PRESENTATION BY.
THE SECRETARY A BOSS CHIANTI.
MISTER JOHN SPANGLER AND MISTER
THOMAS MARTIN AND- LET ME JUST
BE YOU ARE WELCOME TO COME UP
AS I'M INTRODUCING A LITTLE
BACKGROUND ABOUT THE SECRETARY
OF ZACHARY SECRETARY EMBOSSED
KIANA IS A PHYSICIAN A SURGEON
AND A VETERAN HIMSELFHE SERVE
TWENTY SEVEN YEARS IN THE US
ARMY IN THE MEDICAL CORPS. HE
RETIRED IN TWENTY FOURTEEN AT
THE RANK OF COLONEL AND HE'S
BEEN THE DEPARTMENT SECRETARY
SINCE HIS APPOINTMENT BY
GOVERNOR BROWN IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN AND A AGAIN I WILL
REITERATE CONGRADULATIONS ON
YOUR RE APPOINTMENT WE'VE BEEN
WAITING A LONG TIME FOR THAT.
AND I WOULD LIKE TO WELCOME YOU
I'M HERE TODAY AND AGAIN- JOHN
SPANGLER THE DEPUTY DEPUTY
SECRETARY OF LEGISLATION AND
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF VETERAN AFFAIRS
AND THOMAS MARTIN ASSISTANT
DEPUTY SECRETARY. FOR THE
VETERAN HOMES- WELCOME TO ALL
OF YOU AND I DON'T SEE I GUESS
WE MIXED IT AROUND A LITTLE
HIGHER. OKAY WHAT ARE OKAY NO
WELL WHY DON'T MIND AT ALL I
WAS JUST A BIT BUT PERHAPS YOU
CAN MAKE SURE TO INTRODUCE
YOURSELF WHEN YOU SPEAK SO
WELCOME AND- WERE VERY- EXCITED
TO HEAR WHAT YOU HAVE TO SAY
THIS AFTERNOON. SO I WANT TO
GREET THE CHAIR ARCHULETA AND-
AND- NGUYEN AND- THE OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE AND THE
ASSEMBLY VETERANS AFFAIRS
COMMITTEE- WELL FAMILIAR FACES
HERE AND PEOPLE THAT HAVE
SUPPORTED ME. AND THE AGENCY
OVER THE YEARS SOME VERY VERY
GRATEFUL FOR THAT. BOB I WANT
TO THANK YOU ALL FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DISCUSS CAL
THAT'S TWENTY TWENTY. MASTER
PLAN FOR THE VETERANS HOMES AND
HOW IT'S GOING TO GAS A GUIDE
CAL THAT'S PLANNING OVER COMING
DETAILS. THE BOTTOM LINE IS
THAT CALIFORNIA'S VETERANS
POPULATION IS CHANGING IN
SEVERAL WAYS AND THE VETERANS
HOMES MUST CHANGE WITH THEM.
THE LEGISLATURE REQUESTED
CALVET CONDUCTED NEEDS
ASSESSMENT AND A MASTER PLAN
FOR THE HOMES AND WE HAVE DONE
THAT. RESEARCH ON THE WRITING
OF THE MASTER PLAN WAS A
TREMENDOUS UNDERTAKING FOR OUR
DEPARTMENT. FOR THE FIRST TIME
IN OUR SEVENTY THREE YEAR
HISTORY CALVET HAS FULLY
REASSESSED THE VETERANS HOME
SYSTEM. INCLUDING OUR PHYSICAL
PROPERTIES. ARE PROGRAMS OF
CARE AND THE HEALTH CARE NEEDS
OF ALL OF OUR RESIDENTS. CALVET
STAFF COMBINED. A COMB THROUGH
THOUSANDS OF RECORDS TO CAPTURE
DEMOGRAPHIC CHANGES AMONG OUR
RESIDENTS AND THEM AMONG THE
VETERAN COMMUNITY AT LARGE. WE
MET WITH DOZENS OF VETERANS
SERVICE ORGANIZATIONS ELECTED
REPRESENTATIVES LONG TERM CARE
EXPERTS AS WELL AS THE ALLIED
COUNCILS AND OTHER RESIDENTS AT
EVERY HOME. TO ENSURE THAT WE
HAVE A VARIETY OF PERSPECTIVES
TO BOLSTER OUR RECOMMENDATIONS.
SALIM GRATEFUL FOR THE MANY
STAKEHOLDERS WHO OFFERED THEIR
VALUABLE TIME TO CONTRIBUTE TO
THE PROJECT. THE RESULT OF
WHICH IS THIS. THE MASTER PLAN
DAVID TWENTY TWENTY BUT YOU
KNOW THEY'LL BE AN UPDATE EVERY
FIVE YEARS IN PERPETUITY I'M
VERY PROUD OF THIS DOCUMENT
WHAT OUR TEAM HAS BEEN ABLE TO
ACCOMPLISH WITH THE MASTER PLAN
THE DEPTH AND QUALITY OF THE
RESEARCH PAINTS A COMPELLING
PORTRAIT OF TODAY'S AND
TOMORROW'S VETERANS AND WILL
HELP US UNDERSTAND HOW TO MEET
FUTURE VETERANS NEEDS. HOWEVER
I SHOULD MENTION THAT THESE
RECOMMENDATIONS ARE BASED ON
OUR PREDICTIONS OF THE FUTURE
INCLUDING THE ASSUMPTION OF NO
LARGE INCREASE IN THE VETERAN
POPULATION AS WE HAVE LEARNED
OVER THE PAST CENTURY EVERY NEW
WAR CREATES NEW VETERANS THAT
HAS ITS OWN UNIQUE IMPACT ON
THE VETERAN COMMUNITY FIVE MAY
PUT IT MORE BLUNTLY IF THE
UNITED STATES ENGAGES IN ANY
NEW MAJOR CONFLICTS OR WARS
SOME OR ALL OF OUR FINDINGS MAY
NEED RADICAL ECONSIDERATION.
WITHOUT CABBIE OUT MIND LET ME
PROCEED THE MASTER PLAN SERVES
TWO PRIMARY FUNCTIONS FIRST IT
IS A NEEDS ASSESSMENT THAT
EXAMINES TRENDS IN THE VETERANS
COMMUNITY INCLUDING HOW MANY
VETERANS LIVING CALIFORNIA
WHERE THEY LIVE AND HOW THEIR
CARE NEEDS ARE CHANGING. THIS
NEEDS ASSESSMENT ALSO EVALUATES
THE VETERANS HOMES THEMSELVES
BY REVIEWING THE STRENGTHS AND
LIMITATIONS AT EACH CAMPUS.
SECONDLY THE MASTER PLAN IS A
ROADMAP TO GUIDE DISCUSSIONS
ABOUT LONG TERM CAN'T A LONG
TERM PLANNING. INCLUDED IN THE
PLAN ARE TWENTY SEVEN
RECOMMENDATIONS ON A WIDE RANGE
OF SUBJECTS THAT WE ARE
CONFIDENT WILL HELP ENSURE ON
GOING SUCCESS OF ALL EIGHT OF
OUR HOMES. BUT BEFORE I DISCUSS
ANY OF THE RECOMMENDATIONS
SINCE BUT IN PARTICULAR I WANT
TO TALK ABOUT THE VETERAN
POPULATION THAT WE HAVE THE
HONOR TO SERVE. FOR PERHAPS
FORTY YEARS IT'S WORLD WAR TWO
VETERANS THAT HAVE BEEN THE
PRIMARY BENEFICIARIES OF THE
VETERAN HOME SYSTEM. SEVEN OF
OUR EIGHT HOMES WERE
SPECIFICALLY BUILT TO SERVE
WORLD WAR TWO AND KOREA WAR
VETERANS. HOWEVER WE'RE LOSING
THOSE VETERANS AT A RAPID RATE.
AND THIS REPRESENTS A
TREMENDOUS LOSS FOR OUR STATE
IN MANY WAYS BECAUSE CALIFORNIA
BECAME WHAT IT IS TODAY BECAUSE
OF THE GREAT INFLUX OF VETERANS
RETURNING FROM WORLD WAR TWO.
AND WITH THIS SAD LOSS
CALIFORNIA'S VETERAN POPULATION
HAS ALREADY DECREASED BY
SEVERAL HUNDRED THOUSAND OVER
THE PAST DECADE. AND TO MAKE
THAT VISUAL IF YOU WOULD LOOK
AT TABLE ONE IN THE HAND THAT
WE PROVIDED YOU. IT'S THE
DECREASING VETERAN POPULATION
PROJECTED OUT TO TWO THOUSAND
FORTY FIVE. IF YOU WANT TO KNOW
THE SOURCES OF ALL THIS
INFORMATION WE CAN GIVE YOU.
TONS OF FOOTNOTES YOU'LL NOTICE
THAT FIVE YEARS AGO- WHEN I
STARTED WE WERE AT ONE POINT
EIGHT. MILLION VETERANSTODAY
WE ARE AT ONE POINT SIX MILLION
AND THAT NUMBER IS PROJECTED TO
GO DOWN. AS OF JANUARY FIRST OF
THIS YEAR I'M SAID TO SAY THE
UNITED STATES DEPARTMENT OF
VETERANS AFFAIRS PROJECTS THAT
TEXAS NOT CALIFORNIA IS NOW THE
STATE WITH THE LARGEST VETERAN
POPULATION. THIS TREND WILL
CONTINUE WELL INTO THE FUTURE
AND BY THE OR FORTY FORTY THE
VA PROJECTS A 40% DECLINE IN
OUR VETERAN POPULATION. THIS
REDUCTION IS SIGNIFICANT THERE
WILL BE FAR FEWER VETERANS IN
TEN TO TWENTY YEARS. BUT THIS
DECREASEDOES NOT TRANSLATE
INTO A PROPORTIONAL DECLINE IN
THE CARE NEEDS OF VETERANS.
WITH A LOSS OF WORLD WAR TWO
AND KOREA WAR VETERANS COMES A
GENERATIONAL SHIFT. WHICH YOU
MIGHT SEE MORE EASILY IN TABLE
TWO OF THE HAND OUT. TODAY THE
HOMES PRIMARILY SERVE VIETNAM
WAR VETERANS WITH GULF WAR
VETERANS LOOMING ON THE NEAR
HORIZON WE BELIEVE THAT VIETNAM
AND GULF WAR VETERANS ARE FAR
MORE LIKELY TO NEED LONG TERM
CARE. AND TO ME THAT AT YOUNGER
AGES. COMPARED TO WORLD WAR TWO
VETERANS. VETERANS FROM IRAQ
AND AFGHANISTAN ARE THREE TIMES
MORE LIKELY TO RECEIVE A HIGH
DISABILITY RATING FROM THE VA
DEFINED AS GREATER THAN 70%
VIETNAM AND GULF WAR VETERANS
ARE MORE LIKELY THAN THEIR
PREDECESSORS TO HAVE PTSD
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDERS AND
MANY OTHER PHYSICAL AND
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CONDITIONS.
OF ALL THE VETERANS RECEIVING
IN HOME CARE 20% OF THEM SERVED
AFTER NINE ELEVEN DESPITE BEING
RELATIVELY YOUNG FOR DAILY
CARE. THEIR CARE NEEDS ARE FAR
MORE CUTE THAN THOSE OF
VETERANS OF PRIOR JIM
GENERATIONS. YOU CAN SEE THAT
ON TABLE THREE WHERE THE GREEN
LINE IS THE DECREASING
POPULATION OF VETERANS IN
CALIFORNIA. WHILE THE BLUE LINE
IS THE INCREASING DISABILITY
AMONG CALIFORNIA VETERANS. MUCH
OF THIS GENERATIONAL SHIFT CAN
LIKELY BE TRACED BACK TO THE
CHARACTERISTIC OF THE WARS THAT
WE FIGHT THEMSELVES AS A
RETIRED COLONEL OF THE ARMY
MEDICAL CORPS WITH MULTIPLE
DEPLOYMENTS I CAN TELL YOU
FIRST HAND THAT OVER THE LAST
CENTURY THE LETHALITY OF THE
BATTLE FIELD HAS CHANGED AS THE
NATURE OF MODERN COMBAT HAS
CHANGED. VETERANS ARE MORE
LIKELY TO BE DEPLOYED MULTIPLE
TIMES ANDTO BE EXPOSED
EVERYWHERE TO BALLISTIC
INJURIES SEEING THAT THERE IS
NO LONGER A DISTINCTION BETWEEN
WAR ZONES AND SAFE ZONES FOR
THESE REASONS AMONG OTHERS
MODERN SERVICE MEMBERS ARE MORE
LIKELY THAN THEIR PREDECESSORS
TO RETURN HOME WTH PHYSICAL
AND MENTAL HEALTH LIMITATIONS.
IN DEVELOPING MASTER PLAN WE
NOT ONLY LOOKED AT THE VETERANS
WE SERVE WE ALSO TURNED OUR
ATTENTION INWARD TO THE
VETERANS HOMES THAT WE OPERATE.
I AM PROUD OF THE FIVE STAR
CARE WE PROVIDE TO OUR TWO
THOUSAND PLUS RESIDENTS. IT'S
ALSO GRATIFYING THAT MORE THAN
90% OF OUR HOME RESIDENTS HAVE
A POSITIVE OPINION OF THE PLACE
THEY CALL HOME. OUR STAFF IS
THE BEST IN THE COUNTRY AND IT
SHOWS. HOWEVER OUR ANALYSIS
SHOWS THAT SEVERAL HOMES ARE
JUST NOT IN AN IDEAL LOCATION.
NOT IDEAL FOR HIRING STAFF NOT
IDEAL FOR DELIVERING SERVICES
OR FOR DRAWING IN VETERANS FROM
THE NEARBY COMMUNITY. THIS
CAUSES BY AGENCY SIGNIFICANT
CHALLENGES OUR WEST LOS ANGELES
AND YON PHIL HOMES FOR EXAMPLE
ARE FAR FROM COMMUNITIES WITH
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. RESIDENTS
SAID FIVE OF OUR EIGHT HOMES
HAVE TO TRAVEL BY BUS MORE THAN
AN HOUR EACH WAY TO GET TO
THEIR VA SPECIALTY CARE
APPOINTMENTS. AND MORE THAN ARE
HALF OF OUR BARSTOW HOME IS
EMPTY BECAUSE OF ITS REMOTE
LOCATION AND LACK OF DEMAND.
THESE CHALLENGES ARE COMPOUNDED
BY THE CHANGING NEEDS OF THE
RESIDENTS IN OUR HOMES AND FOR
A MOMENT I'D LIKE TO SHIFT. TO
HAVE THOMAS MARTIN THE PRIMARY
AUTHOR OF THE MASTER PLAN.
OUTLINED THE STRUCTURE IN THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE REPORT AND
DISCUSS HOW THE CHANGE YOU
RESIDENT POPULATIONS IMPACT OUR
OPERATIONS. AND ALL CLOSE WHEN
HE FINISHES. OKAY THANK YOU
MISTER SCRETARY- SECTORS BUT
ONLY ONLY BEEN ON THE JOB FOR A
COUPLE OF DAYS BUT- IT SEEMS
THAT REALLY PICKED IT UP AND-
OVER A SHORT TIME HERE. SO AS A
SECTOR MENTION CREATING THE
MASTER PLAN WAS A MAJOR
UNDERTAKING FOR A FORD FOR THE
DEPARTMENT FOR A STAFF. OF THE
REQUIRED A LOT OF COLLABORATION
WITH- WITH OUR RESIDENTS- AND
WITH STAKEHOLDERS- WE HELD A
NUMBER OF WORKSHOPS REBT
STATES- WITH- AT DOZENS OF
EXTERNAL STAKEHOLDERS- AS OUR
DIMENSION LEGISLATORS ELECTED
OFFICIALS- VETERANS SERVICE-
ORGANIZATIONS- AND WE ALSO MET
WITH MORE THAN A HUNDRED
RESIDENTS. TO GET THEIR
FEEDBACK ON HOMES WE ALSO- WE
ALSO CONDUCTED TWO SURVEYS OF
ALL THE RESIDENTS IN OUR HOMES.
AT TO MAKE SURE WE REALLY
UNDERSTANDING WHAT THEY SAW AS
THE CURRENT TRAJECTORY OF HOMES
IN WTH A- WITH A FEW FELT THE
AT THE FUTURE SHOULD HAVE FOR
THEM. SO I THE DEVELOPING THE
STRUCTURE OF THE DRUM OF THE
MASTER PLAN IN THE STRUCTURE
THAT IN ITS- NEAR EACH OTHER'S
WHEN WE WHEN WE STARTED THE
FIRST STEP. WAS UNDERSTANDING
HOW MANY VETERANS WE HAVE
ACROSS THE STATE- WHERE THEY'RE
LOCATED- WHETHER AGES WERE THAT
HAVE INFORMATION ON TO GET A
DEMOGRAPHIC BASS LINE JUST
UNDERSTAND ON WHAT THE
POPULATION IS THAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT- AND ALSO HOW IT'S
HOW IT'S GONNA BE CHANGING THE
FUTURE. OF THE NEXT THING WE
DID IS WE COLLECTED HEALTH
DATA. FROM A VARIETY OF
SOURCES- TO UNDERSTAND HOW THE
KERANIQUE FOR SHIFTING IN THE
POPULATION ITSELF- TO SEE HOW
MUCH YOU SEE IF THEY REALLY
CORRELATE EACH OTHER. AND AS
THE AS THE SECRETARY SAID.
WE'VE WE'VE GOT A REAL
INTERESTING TRY THE BETTER
POPULATION. IS DECLINING-
CLEARLY IT'S GOING TO CLIMB BY
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNTS- BUT- THOSE
HEALTHCARE NEEDS ARE NOT
DECLINING AT THE SAME RATE. I
HELP HER NEED TO CONTINUE TO
GROW- LIKELY DUE TO THE
INCREASING ACUITY OF THE NEEDS
OF VETERANS. AS WELL AS THE-
THE PREVALENCE OF MULTIPLE
OUTCOME OF IT CALL MORBID OR CO
OCCURRING CONDITIONS. OUR WITH
THIS DATA. ARE WE CAN FIX
CAMPUS OTHER CARE PROVIDERS- TO
FIND TO IDENTIFY WHAT OTHER
SERVICES BEING PROVIDED OUT OUT
FOR THE BETTER COMMUNITY. AND
ALSO UNDERSTAND WHAT THE WHAT
THE SHORTCOMINGS WERE WITH THE
GAPS WERE. AND WHAT OUR ROLE
SHOULD BE IN AN ADDRESSING
THOSE SO IN THE PROCESS WE
IDENTIFIED. WE DETERMINE THAT
WE WERE REALLY THE ONLY MAJOR
PROVIDER OF. A FACILITY BASED
LONG TERM CARE. LIKELY BECAUSE
OF THE- THE PROGRAMMATIC
COMPLEXITY OF TRYING TO
OPERATE. ON THOSE TYPES OF
FACILITIES AS WELL AS THE- THE
HIGH COST OF SKILLED NURSING
AND GENERAL. OF WE ALSO
REVIEWED WORKFORCE AND
RESEARCH DATA FOR EACH SHOT FOR
REGION THROUGHOUT THE STATE. TO
IDENTIFY AREAS WHERE CURRENT
AND POTENTIAL HYPOTHETICAL
VETERANS HOMES ARE WHERE THAT
WHERE THEY MIGHT BE SUCCESSFUL-
AND I IT WILL TRY TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND WHAT KIND OF WHAT
KIND OF LOCAL RESOURCES YOU
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT WOULD BE
SUCCESSFUL. OF FINALLY WE
REVIEWED OUR OWN INTERNAL DATA
ON THE HOMES- WEEK WE COLLECTED
AND MANUALLY REVIEWED MORE THAN
TEN THOUSAND RECORDS. TO
UNDERSTAND- OUR RESIDENTS
DEMOGRAPHICS THE CHANGES IN THE
CARE NEEDS- WHAT KIND OF
DIAGNOSES THEY HAVE. A WHAT
KIND OF CHALLENGES THE HOMES
FACE- RELATED INFRASTRUCTURE
RELATES TO WORK FORCE- THAT
TYPE OF DATA TO REALLY
UNDERSTAND- HOW THAT WAS GOING
IMPACTS FOR THE FUTURE AND HOW
WE CAN BEST PREPARE FOR IT. SO
AS OUR TO MENTION SOME OF THE
DATA WAS WAS REALLY EYE
OPENING- LAST SUMMER- AS MUCH
WE COLLECTED A NUMBER OF
INTERNAL RECORDSAND THE
PROCESS WE REVIEWED EVERY
SINGLE RESIDENTS- MEDICAL
RECORDS AT EVERY HOME. I SO
WHEN WE WHEN WE DID THAT WE
IDENTIFIED- WAIT WE DETERMINE
THAT THE PROP ABOUT TWO THIRDS
OF OUR VIETNAM WAR VETERANS
CURRENTLY LIVING IN A HOMES
HAVE AT LEAST ONE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH AT DIAGNOSIS ABOUT TWO
THIRDS COMPARED TO ONLY 40%
AMONG HERBAL WERE TO RESIDENTS.
I FURTHER MORE THAN 80% OF OUR
VETERANS UNDER THE AGE OF SIXTY
FIVE HAD AT LEAST ONE DIAGNOSIS
SO. TWO THIRDS OF VIETNAM
VETERANS 40% OF OVER TWO BUT
MORE THAN 80% OF OUR YOUNGER
VETERANS UNDER SIXTY FIVE. THEY
ARE BECAUSE OF THERE'S THIS
GROWING NEED WE CAN SEE THIS AS
THE THAT AS- KIND OF THE START
OF A GROWING WAVE THAT'S GOING
TO COMING TOWARDS US- WE CAN WE
RECOGNIZE THAT OUR MIDDLE HAS
HEALTH STAFFER ARE STRUGGLING
TO MEET. MEET THE DEMAND FOR
SERVICES AND TO KEEP KEEP PACE
WITH THE CHANGES. SIMILARLY THE
DEMAND FOR SKILLED NURSING IS
ALSO VERY HIGH- IN THE LAST TEN
YEARS WE OPEN FIVE NEW VETERANS
HOMES- IN THE PROCESS WE
DOUBLED OUR CAPACITY FOR
SKILLED NURSING. ACROSS THE
SYSTEM- DESPITE THIS WE STILL
HAVE A LOT OF DEMAND AND- LEAVE
THE WEIGHTLESS FOR SKILLED
NURSING UNITS- COMPARATIVELY
THERE'S LITTLE DEMAND FOR OUR
DOMICILIARY CARE UNITS AND OUR
IMMEDIATE CARE UNITS- EACH
WHICH- IS. OUTDATED AND HAS
SOMEWHAT LIMITED USE FOR
TODAY'S VETERANS. OUR RESIDENT
POPULATIONS CHANGE DRAMATICALLY
OVER THE LAST DECADE AND WE CAN
EXPECT ALL THESE TRENDS TO
CONTINUE INTO THE FUTURE- AND-
SO FOR MORE GENERATION ABOUT
THE LIVES CARE WE CORPORATE
CURRENTLY PROVIDE AND THE AT
THE BUDGET BETS AT EACH. ARE
YOU CAN TAKE A LOOK AT THAT
TABLE FOUR ON PAGE TO THE
HANDOUT. SO BASED ON ALL THIS
INFORMATION COLLECTED- WITHIN A
FIVE TWENTY SEVEN
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR
CONSIDERATION. EACH OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS IS SUPPORTED BY
THE DATA WE COLLECTED- BOTH
INTERNAL AND EXTERNAL DATA AS
WELL AS THE- THE WEALTH OF
STAKEHOLDER INFORMATION WE- WE-
WE RECEIVED THROUGHOUT THE
PROCESS. SO WITH THAT I'LL TURN
IT OVER TO THE SECRETARY TO
WALK TO THE RECOMMENDATIONS AND
HOW THEY FIT INTO OUR FUTURE.
SOME OF. SO WHAT DO ALL THESE
FACTS IN MIND THE MASTER PLAN
OFFERS CONCRETE STEPS FOR
CALIFORNIA TO PREPARE FOR THE
FUTURE OF LONG TERM CARE
VETERAN CARE WE MUST BEGIN
TAILORING OUR PROGRAMS FOR
VIETNAM AND GULF WAR VETERANS
NOW IN ORDER TO PROVIDE THE
RIGHT SERVICES WHEN THE TIME
COMES AND TO MAXIMIZE OUR
RESOURCES FOR THE BENEFITS OF
ALL OF OUR RESIDENTS. SO TO
START. WE RECOMMEND ELIMINATING
INTERMEDIATE CARE. AS A LEVEL
OF CARE. AND REDUCING
DOMICILIARY CARE AND INSTEAD
FOCUS ON ASSISTED LIVING AND
SKILLED NURSING WHICH HAVE FAR
GREATER DEMAND AND HAVE PROVEN
MORE EFFECTIVE. THE LEVEL OF
CARE IS THOMAS MENTIONED IS-
DELINEATED ON- TABLE FOR WHICH
IS THE SECOND PAGE OF YOUR HAND
OUT. JUST A FOOTNOTE OR IT MAY
BE A PARENTHESIS- INTERMEDIATE
CARE IS A DINOSAUR LEVEL OF
CARE IF IT EXISTS. IN VERY VERY
FEW PLACES IN CALIFORNIA AND
THEY'RE ALL RUN BY THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THAT EXISTS IN OUR
VETERANS HOMES AND IN THE STATE
HOSPITALS AND THAT'S IT. OF
PEOPLE WHO ARE AN INTERMEDIATE
CARE CARE COULD EASILY UPGRADE
EITHER TO A SKILLED NURSING
BAD. OR MOVE DOWN DEPENDING ON
HOW MANY ACTIVITIES OF DAILY
LIVING THEY CAN ACCOMPLISH DOWN
TO THE ASSISTED LIVING. WE
COULD EASILY. PHASE THAT AWAY
WHEN I SAY GET RID OF THAT
LEVEL OF CARE I DO NOT MEAN.
DISMISSING ANY SINGLE RESIDENT
FROM THE HOME WHO'S IN THAT
LEVEL OF CARE. THEY WOULD JUST
BE ASSIGNED TO A DIFFERENT ONE.
THIS YEAR THE ADMINISTRATION
HAS SUBMITTED THE PCP TO DO
JUST THAT STARTING THE LONG
PROCESS. OF RESHAPING OUR
BARSTOW CHULA VISTA AND YON
PHIL HOMES BY REFOCUSING
EFFORTS AND RESOURCES ON MORE
APPROPRIATE LEVELS OF CARE TO
BE CLEAR ONCE AGAIN NO CURRENT
RESIDENT OF ANY HOME WOULD BE
JUST CHARGED AS PART OF ANY
TRANSITION EFFORT. THE B. C. P.
THAT ACCOMPANIES THE MASTER
PLAN ALSO IMPROVES BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH STAFFING ACROSS THE
SYSTEM ENSURING THAT OUR
RESIDENTS HAVE BETTER ACCESS TO
PSYCHIATRISTS PSYCHOLOGISTS AND
SOCIAL WORKERS WHEN THEY NEED
THEMOST. THE MASTER PLAN
INCLUDES RECOMMENDATIONS FOR
EACH OF OUR VETERANS HOMES
INCLUDING SEVERAL FOR THE YOUNG
FULL CAMPUS ALONE. MOST
CRITICALLY THE MASTER PLAN
HIGHLIGHTS THE NEED TO REPLACE
THEIR THE AGING HALDEMAN
BUILDING WITH A NEW STATE OF
THE ART SKILLED NURSING
FACILITY. AND WITHOUT IT THE
HOME CANNOT PROVIDE THE QUALITY
OF CARE FOR COMING GENERATIONS
OF VETERANS. A MASTER PLAN ALSO
SUGGEST SUGGEST EXPANDING
PROPERTY USE AT THE YOUNG FILL
HOME TO MAXIMIZE THE USE OF THE
LAND WITHOUT PLACING BURDENS ON
THE GENERAL FUND. OF COURSE ANY
SUCH PROPERTY USE HAS TO FOLLOW
THE LAW AND PROVIDE A BENEFIT
TO RESIDENTS OF THE HOME BUT I
BELIEVE THERE ARE OPPORTUNITIES
FOR GROWTH THAT MEET OUR
STATUTORY OBLIGATIONS WHILE
ALLOWING FOR GREATER SUPPORT.
OF CALIFORNIA'S VETERANS. THESE
ARE ONLY A FEW OF THE TWENTY
SEVEN RECOMMENDATIONS IN THE
MASTER PLAN BRIEFLY SOME OF THE
OTHERS WOULD SUGGEST THE
FOLLOWING. ONE IMPROVE
COORDINATION WITH SUPPORT OF
HOUSING PROGRAMS SUCH AS V. H.
H. P. TO ENSURE THAT THE HOMES
CAN AFFECT EFFECTIVELY SERVE
HOMELESS VETERANS. THOSE WHO
ARE IN NEED OF LONG TERM CARE.
TO PROVIDE CLEAR CRITERIA FOR
DEVELOPING ANY FUTURE VETERANS
HOME TO ENSURE THAT THEY ARE
LOCATED IN THE MOST APPROPRIATE
COMMUNITIES. LET ME MAKE SURE
I'M I'M CLEAR I'M NOT PROPOSING
THE CALVET START THE
CONSTRUCTION OF ANY NEW
VETERANS HOMES BUT IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE TAKE A LOOK AT ME THAT
WITH ME AT TABLE FIVE. ON PAGE
TWO. IT'S PROBABLY THE SINGLE
MOST SLOW AT. THE SLIDE I'M I'M
MOST- PROUD OF HERE. ACROSS THE
TOP WHAT WHAT CREATES THE
COLUMNS ARE WHAT I CALL VETOES
FIVE RULES FOR FUTURE VETERAN
HOME CONSTRUCTION. A BETTER A
NEW VETERANS HOME MUST BE
LOCATED IN AN AREA WHERE
THERE'S A HIGH DENSITY OF
VETERANS AND THERE'S A HIGH
NEED. THERE MUST BE ACROSS THE
STREET FROM A VA OR IF NOT THIS
CLOSE TO ONE AS YOU CAN GET. IT
HAS TO OFFER APPROPRIATE LEVELS
OF CARE AND THOSE LEVELS OF
CARE NEED TO EXIST IN THE
COMMUNITY. THAT'S THE FOURTH
COLUMN THERE HASTO BE A LOCAL
HEALTH CARE- INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND FINALLY FIVE IT REALLY
HELPS TO BE ABLE FOR OUR ENTRY
LEVEL- A HIRING. A STAFF NURSES
AND PHARMACISTS THERAPISTS
EVERYBODY TO BE ABLE TO LIVE
WITHIN A REASONABLE- LOCATION.
SO WHAT WE'VE DONE IS THIS IS A
REPORT CARD ON EVERYONE OF THE
HOMES. AND YOU'LL SEE. OF
WHETHER THE AT THE HOME
LOCATION WAS APPROPRIATE WHEN
IT WAS CONSTRUCTED OR NOT
THERE'S OF THE GRADES THEY GET
NOW. NUMBER THREE MAKE
PERMANENT. PLEASE BUT- THE
CURRENT FISCAL YEARS
OPERATIONAL EXPENSE ADJUSTMENTS
FOR THE THREE OLDER HOMES THOSE
ARE THE ONES BILL BEFORE TWO
THOUSAND. WHICH IS INCLUDED IN
ANOTHER BCP CURRENTLY PENDING A
REVIEW. FOR OPERATE OP EVALUATE
OPTIONS TO PROVIDE MUCH NEEDED
DEMENTIA CARE STARTING WITH THE
UNIT ARE AT OUR CHULA VISTA
HOME. AND FIVE REASSESS LEVELS
OF CARE AT OUR FIVE NEWEST
HOMES TO PROVIDE MORE EFFECTIVE
SERVICES WITH- WITHIN LOCAL
RESOURCES. SO I'M CONFIDENT
THAT IMPLEMENTING THESE
RECOMMENDATIONS WILL MAKE SURE
THE HOMES CONTINUE TO BE
SUCCESSFUL FOR DECADES TO COME.
HOWEVER I KNOW I CANNOT ACT ON
THESE ALONE AND I ASK FOR THE
HELP OF THE LEGISLATURE THE
RESIDENTS IN OUR HOMES OUR
STAFF AND ALL OF OUR
STAKEHOLDERS TO SEE THEM
THROUGH TO FRUITION. AS I'VE
MENTIONED THE LEGISLATURE NOW
HAS SEVERAL BCP'S THAT WOULD
ENACT SOME OF THE MOST FAR
REACHING RECOMMENDATIONS OTHER
BUDGET OR LEGISLATIVE PROPOSALS
MAY COME IN FUTURE YEARS TO
FURTHER THESE RECOMMENDATIONS
FOR TO MAKE THEM COMPLY WITH
OTHERS. COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT
PLAYED A SIGNIFICANT ROLE IN
DEVELOPING THE MASTER PLAN AND
I'M CONVINCED THAT MUST PLAY A
SIMILAR ROLE IN IMPLEMENTING
THAT. CALIFORNIA ALONG WITH ME
WITH THE FIRST STATES TO OPEN A
VETERANS HOME AND TIME AND TIME
AGAIN FOR A HUNDRED AND THIRTY
FIVE YEARS NOW WE HAVE
REPEATEDLY MADE BOLD
COMMITMENTS TO OUR MEN AND
WOMEN IN ARMS. TO HOUSE THEM
WHEN THEY NEED SHELTER TO
EDUCATE THEM WHEN THEY NEED
JOBS TO CARE FOR THEM WHEN THEY
AGE. THIS MASTER PLAN
REPRESENTS YET ANOTHER BOLD
COMMITMENT. IN OUR COLLECTIVE
EFFORTS TO BETTER HONOR
CALIFORNIA'S VETERANS. WE MUST
NOT FORGET THAT MANY OF OUR
VETERANS NEED LONG TERM CARE.
BECAUSE OF INJURIES THEY BORE
WHILE WEARING OUR NATION'S
UNIFORMS AND PROTECTING OUR
PEOPLE OUR FREEDOMS AND OUR
VALUES. IT'S UP TO US TOGETHER
TO MAKE SURE THAT CALIFORNIA'S
VETERANS CONTINUE TO RECEIVE
THE CARE AND THE DIGNITY THEY
HAVE EARNED. AND TO MAKE SURE
OUR VETERANS HOMES CAN THRIVE
FOR THE NEXT HUNDRED AND THIRTY
FIVE YEARS. SO I THANK YOU FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT OUR
WORK PRODUCT TO YOU. AND WE'RE
GOING TO BE HAPPY TO TAKE
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT I THANK YOU
OF VERY MUCH FOR THAT
PRESENTATION AND- ONE OF
WELCOME ALL THE SENATORS AND
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS THAT ARE
HERE TODAY THANK YOU FOR.
JOINING US. AND NOW WE'RE OPEN
FOR QUESTIONS. DO WE HAVE.
SENATOR OFF. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR. SECRETARY GOOD TO SEE
YOU. LOOKING AT THE- THE
BARSTOW HOME SCORE CARD WHICH.
LARGELY A SERIES OF RED AXIS
DID TAKE A LOOK TO
RECOMMENDATIONS. THE REPORT
INDICATES THAT THERE'S A DEMAND
FOR SKILLED NURSING FACILITY
BEDS THAT OBVIOUSLY- MUST
EXCEED THE CAPABILITY OF THE
FACILITY- DOES THAT MEAN THAT
THE- THAT THE COMMERCIAL
OPERATORS IN THE COMMUNITY AND
THEN THE AREA ARE AND ARE NOT
CAPABLE OF. ACCOMMODATING THESE
SKILLED NURSING FACILITY.
OCCUPANTS WERE CLIENTS. I KNOW
THAT- WE HAVE A DEMAND THAT BAR
SO AT AS IT IN OTHER PLACES
WEEK CAL THAT FOR SKILLED
NURSING WE DO NOT HAVE A DEMAND
FOR DOMICILIARY LEVEL CARE OR
FOR INTERMEDIATE CARE THERE-
ALSO. IN A AYE AYE ONLY HALF
JOKINGLY SAY THAT I COULD WALK
OUTSIDE THIS BUILDING ENCOUNTER
HOMELESS VETERAN ON THE CAPITOL
MALL OFFER HIM A PLACE TO SLEEP
TONIGHT AND THREE SQUARE MEALS
STARTING TOMORROW MORNING BUT I
CAN'T GET THEM TO MOVE TO
BARSTOW. YEAH SO I HAVE A
STRUGGLE WITH WITH THAT SO
THAT'S WHY ONLY A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY OF OUR HUNDRED AND
HUNDRED A HUNDRED EIGHTY OF OUR
FOUR HUNDRED BEDS ARE FILLED
THERE YOU'RE ASKING ME TO FOR A
COMMENT ON THE- LONG TERM CARE
NURSING FACILITIES ANNOUNCING A
MAKE MY QUESTION CLEAR I MEAN I
GUESS MY QUESTION IS GIVEN THE
DIFFICULTY ASSOCIATED WITH THE
BURST OF FACILITY. AND OUR
DESIRE AS THE LEGISLATURE AND I
ASSUME IS AN ADMINISTRATION TO
MAKE SURE THAT OUR VETERANS
RECEIVE ABSOLUTELY THE CARE-
THAT THEY NEED AND CLEARLY
DESERVE IS IT POSSIBLE IN THE
COMMUNITY THEN IF WE WANTED TO
DO SO BUT WHEN IT'S THERE WITH
LEGISLATIVE POLITICAL WILL TO
DO IT. TO TAKE THE POPULAR OF
SKILLED NURSING FACILITY TODAY
IN THE THAT WE WOULD LIKE TO
ACCOMMODATE IN THE SKILLED
NURSING FACILITY AND THE
POPULATION THAT NEEDS ASSISTED
CARE WHETHER YOU CALL IT
INTERMEDIATE CARE OR ASSISTED
LIVING. AND MAKE THAT CARE
AVAILABLE THROUGH CONTRACT
FACILITIES IN THE COMMUNITY- TO
SO IN SOME WAY. THAN MAY OF AT
HOME. STATE FACILITY AND
PROVIDE THE SAME LEVEL OF CARE
AT LOW COST OR NO COST. YEAH
YES BROADLY SPEAKING PARDON ANY
NEW ACCOMMODATION I THINK STILL
HAS TO MEET FIVE RULES- SO. THE
VERY FIRST ROLE WOULD BE IS
THAT AN AREA WITH A HIGH
VETERAN DENSITY THE INLAND
EMPIRE HAS AN EXTRAORDINARILY
DENSE- VETERAN POPULATION BUT
THERE FOCUSED MORE IN THE
BIGGER CITIES RIVERSIDE AND SAN
BERNARDINO- AT WE COULD WE
COULD HAVE EASILY HYPOTHESIZE
THAT WERE THERE TO BE A MOVE
CAN. CONSIDER MOVE SUCH AS THAT
THAT THOSE LARGER METROPOLITAN
AREAS WOULD BE WHERE I WOULD GO
LOOKING WELL FOR A FOR OF STATE
FACILITY YEAH MY QUESTION IS
YOU HAVE A CENSUS OF FORTY IN
THE SKILLED NURSING FACILITY SO
THEY'RE FORTY BEDS THAT ARE
OCCUPIED- DOES A LOCAL
COMMUNITY HAVE THE CAPABILITY
TO ABSORB THE FORTY ADDITIONAL
PATIENTS AND THEY DON'T FEEL
WHAT YOU WOULD LOSE BECAUSE
ONCE AGAIN THIS THOMAS- FAIRLY
ELOQUENTLY SAID EARLY ON. ON
CAL THAT IS THE ONLY ENTITY IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THAT
OFFERS VETERANS A LONG TERM
CARE OPTION IN COMMUNITY. THERE
ARE EVERY NURSING HOME IN
CALIFORNIAHAS VETERANS THEY
MIGHT HAVE A HUNDRED RESIDENTS
WITH THE THREE OF THEM ARE
VETERANS AND I DARE SAY THEY
DON'T GET A SPECIAL. TREATMENT
FOR THAT YOU MEAN YOU MEAN. BY
A FACILITY THAT IS. INTERESTED
IN PARTICULARLY INTERESTED IN
THE VETERANS WELFARE. IT HAS
NOTHING TO DO WITH COST WHO
PAYS EXACTLY EXACTLY WHAT IS
THERE THAT'S THE INTANGIBLE
BENEFIT OF RUNNING A FACILITY
CREEKS AND JUST TO JUST TO KIND
OF JUMP IN SO WHEN WE WHEN WE
DID- WE DID OUR INTERVIEWS
WITH- WITH- WITH RESIDENTS-
THEY WERE COUPLE OF RESPONSES I
THINK WE'RE KIND OF ON POINTS
THAT NUMBER OF A RESIDENTS WERE
NOT INTERESTED IN A NURSING
HOME- THEY WERE INTERESTED IN
VETERANS HOME THEY'RE WILLING
TO GO TO VETERANS HOME BUT THEY
WERE NOT INTERESTED IN. OTHER
OTHER LONG TERM CARE THAT
WASN'T ABOUT AND SEE IF THEY
FELT THAT I MIGHT BE IN SKILLED
NURSING UNIT BUT I'M NOT IN A
NURSING HOME I'M IN A VETERANS
HOME SO IT'S SOMETHING THAT'S
THAT'S KIND OF AN ATTENTION
THING THAT WAS IMPORTANT TO
THEM- OTHERS HAD COME FROM A
PRIVATE SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES- INCLUDING- SO THE
VA THE VA ANY RIGHT WHERE THE
VA PROVIDES- THAT PROVIDES A
SKILLED NURSING CONTRACTED OUT.
TO PAY ON DISABILITY RATINGS IN
THE PRIORITIZATION SYSTEM- SO
NUMBER OF VETERANS DID GETS-
SKILLED NURSING TO PRIVACY THAT
WAS FREE FOR THEM- AND THEY
STILL CAME TO US BECAUSE THEY
FELT THE WORDS- THEY WEREN'T
UNDERSTOOD OR THEY THEY WEREN'T.
THEY FELT THEY'D- DIDN'T BLAND.
WITH THE PRIVATE. POPULATION
AND ONE LAST QUESTION DO WE
KNOW WHETHER FOR EXAMPLE YOUR
CENSUS OF FORTY IN THE SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES TO IS THE-
AS TO THE AS OF THE DATE OF
THIS REPORT. THOSE FORTY
INDIVIDUALS WERE CAME TO US
FROM THE BARSTOW AREA OR DID
THEY COME TO US FROM.
GEOGRAPHICALLY REMOTE LOCATIONS
DO WE KNOW THAT SO AT SO- WE
DID WE DID CANVAS THE RESIDENTS
TO FIND OUT WHERE EXACTLY THEY
CAME FROM- LOS RESIDENTES CAME
FROM WITH A HUNDRED MILES
THAT'S THAT'S GENERALLY ACROSS
ALL IT COMES. ON THE CAME
WITHIN A HUNDRED MILES FOR
SKILLED NURSING AND FOR
ASSISTED LIVING AND PRIMARILY
INDEPENDENT LIVING MAINLY
WITHIN FIFTY MILES OR LESS- IN
LOOKING A BAR STONE PARTICULAR
THAT THE BOOK OF THEM AB CAME
FROM. LOOKED AT BURNSIDE SALMON
DINO MUCH PERSONAL METROPOLITAN
AREA TO BARSTOW TO BURST RIGHT
WITHOUT IT IS NOT VERY MANY WHO
CAME FROM THE IMMEDIATE. AREA
WILL GIVE YOU OPTIONS TO IN
ORDER TO KEEP THE VETERANS
POPULATION HAPPY THEY'RE
DRIVING OR- COMING. COME TO
BARS SO FROM SOME PLACE. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR. THANK YOU
SENATE UMBERG. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND- MISTER CHAIR THANK
YOU FOR WORKING ISING THIS
HEARING IS INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT
ISSUE THAT I THINK HASN'T BEEN-
GIVEN ENOUGH AWARENESS IN THE
LEGISLATURE SO THANK YOU FOR
THAT CONGRATULATIONS ON YOUR
REAPPOINTMENT MISTER SECRETARY
AND- CONGRATULATIONS TO YOUR
STAFF AYE AYES SUSPECTED THEY
ACTUALLY HELP YOU WRITE THIS
REPORT THAT ARE- THIS IS QUITE
COMPREHENSIVE AND ALSO HAS BEEN
COMPREHENSIVE THERE ARE SOME
VERY CRITICAL ELEMENTS IN THE
REPORT LEAST PORTIONS THAT THAT
I'VE READ IN AND I COMMEND YOU
FOR BEING WHAT APPEARS TO BE
VERY OBJECTIVE IN YOUR
ASSESSMENT OF. WHERE THE HOMES
APART I HAVE A FEW QUESTIONS
LET ME ASK A FEW AND THEN
PERHAPS TURN OVER TO OTHER
MEMBERS FOR THE THEIR QUESTION-
SO I SEE ON PAGE FIVE OF THE
REPORTS IS NEARLY 85% OF THE
WAIT LIST OF APPLICANTS REQUET
SKILLED NURSING OR MEMORY KERR
SO THAT WOULD INDICATE TO ME
THAT THAT WE'VE GOT OUR
FACILITY. ARE NOT A WITH THE
MAN IS THAT HOW YOU AS WELL
ABSOLUTELY JOB FOR EXAMPLE IT
DOWN FILL THIS LONG WAITING
LISTS FOR THOSE OF HIGHER TWO
LEVELS OF CARE ZERO WAITING
LIST FOR YEARS FOR DOMICILIARY.
THEN PERHAPS IT'S IN THE REPORT
BUT BUT HOW MANY OF THE HOME
PROVIDE MEMORY CARE. TODAY I
THE YOUNG FILL WEST LOS ANGELES
READING AND FRESNO- VETERANS
HOMES SO FORTY FOUR OF THE
EIGHT FOR THE SIDE. MEMORY
KERR- IN WHAT'S WHAT'S BEING
DONE TO EXPAND IT TO ALL LATER
OR BE ON THOSE FOR- WE'RE
STARTING WITH A REQUEST WILL BE
WITH THE PCC AND DRY CHICKEN.
SINCE I GOT HERE I'VE HEARD-
FROM CHULA VISTA AREA OF
COMMUNITY THERE'S A NEED FOR
DEMENTIA CARE THERE AND THIS IS
MY FIRST OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS
THAT. IN IS THAT ALL IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. YOU SAID AS
A B. C. P. THERE IS THAT ALSO
PART OF THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
SORRY I THINK I THINK THE
SECTOR AREA COMPUTER THING SO
I'M NOT THAT ONE'S NOT IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET THIS YEAR
THAT IS SOMETHING WE WANT
EXPLORE FOR THE FUTURE WHETHER
IT'S- YOU KNOW WHETHER TO THE
BUDGET PROCESS OR- TO SOME
OTHER METHOD. THE FIRST WE NEED
DO IS EVALUATE THE EXISTING
FACILITY- TO DETERMINE WHAT CAN
BE HOW CAN BE MODIFIED TO
ACCOMMODATE AB OR CARE SO WE
REALLY SEE IT AS A HUGE BLACK
HOLE BECAUSE- THE CITY GO
POPULOUS CAN OVER. LOS ANGELES
COUNTY AND FOR YEARS OF. ON THE
COME THE- OF BETTER LOOKS
BETTER DENSE BUT THE NEAREST
NOW THAN YOUR STANDARD SO WITH
MEMBER CARE IS IN WEST LOS. YOU
KNOW TO NOT HOURS AWAY TO LIVE
IN SAN DIEGO MAYBE MORE SO
RELEASE THAT SOME WE NEED TO
START LOOKING FOR THE FUTURE SO
POTENTIALLY WE WOULD WE WOULD
MODIFY EXIST SKINNER. IS
PROVIDE THAT. OKAY BUT BUT BACK
TO THE MONEY SURE IT THIS IS
THE. CURRENT BUDGET THE.
HOWEVER IT DOWN IN THE IN THE
CURRENT BUDGET THERE ARE. THERE
IS A BEAST HE- AT ATTACHED TO
THE MASTER PLAN- THAT LOOKS AT
REALIGNING LEVELS OF CARE SO
FOR EXAMPLE- AS AN RAFI
MENTIONED YEAH THERE'S HIGH
DEMAND FOR SKILLED NURSING IN
BARSTOW- BUT THAT AT THE- AT
THE HOME RIGHT NOW SO WE'RE-
ONE OF THE RECOMMENDATIONS AS
TO. TO EXPAND THE SKILLED
NURSING WHILE SIMULTANEOUSLY-
CONVERTING A DRAWING DOWN THE
INDEPENDENT IN AN IMMEDIATE
CARE UNIT SO. SO WE'RE WE'RE
LOOKING KIND OF STRATEGICALLY
AT HOW CAN WE CHANGE THOSE
LEVELS OF KERR- START CHANGING
NOW TO MEET THE DEMAND THAT
AVERY SAYING AND BE THAT WE
THINK WE'RE GONNA SEE IN THE
NEXT TEN OR TWENTY YEARS. UPSET
WE ARE STARTING THE PROCESS
WITH THIS YEAR'S BUDGET. THIS
I'M SORRY I DID COME A WRECK.
WITH THE RECENT. SORRY ABOUT
THAT. OKAY AND MAYBE ALL LINE
WE CAN MEET TALK ABOUT. WHAT
WHAT ADDITIONAL FOR OR WHAT
FUNDS CURRENTLY IN THE BUDGET
TO ACCOMPLISH THE GOALS THAT
YOU SET OUT AND RECOMMENDATIONS
THAT YOU YOU'VE SET OUT HERE-
YOU ALSO ON ON PAGE FOUR- YOU
YOU TALK ABOUT HOW- VIETNAM
VETS AND POST VIETNAM VETS.
HAVE A HIGHER NEED FOR
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AND MENTAL
HEALTH NEEDS AS OPPOSED TO WERE
WERE TO INCREASE IN MORE VETS
AND DISK. AS TO WHAT WHAT THE-
BECAUSE FACTORS ARE. WHERE TO
START OF WORLD WAR TWO VETERANS
WENT OFF WANTS TO WAR CAME BACK
AND- THE LIMIT THE AMOUNT OF
TIME THAT THEY WERE EXPOSED TO
THE KIND OF BALLISTIC INJURIES
OF THE MILLIONS OF PEOPLE IN
UNIFORM A SMALLER PROPORTION
WERE EXPOSED IN THAT WAY-
CURRENT CONFLICT VETERANS ARE
GOING OFF REPETITIVELY FOUR
YEAR LONG ROTATIONS- THEY'RE IN
CONSTANT EXPOSURE TO AYE EDIE'S
AND ROCKETS MORTARS AND WHAT
HAVE YOU. IT'S THE INJURIES TO
THE BRAIN SO I JOKE. THAT WHEN
THE NAM WHEN WE WAR TWO QUE TO
THE VETERANS HOMES THEY CAME TO
A SUDDEN OLDER GE WITH TWO
SUITCASES AND TWO DIAGNOSES
HIGH BLOOD PRESSURE GLAUCOMA.
JUST GENERIC FOR EASY TO TREAT
THINGS NOW OUR SOLDIERS ARE
COMING BACK WITH. MULTIPLE
DIAGNOSIS FROM THE COLLAR BONE
UP MORE DIFFICULT TO HANDLE
EXACERBATING THEIR UNDERLYING
MEDICAL CONDITIONS WITH THEIR
BEHAVIOR ON MENTAL HEALTH
THINGS OF PTSD- SO. THAT'S
THAT'S THE START OF IT. THE
START OF THE IT IT'S HARD FROM
TO READ BUT BUT I READ THE
PRESIDENT I'D STATES OF JUST
JUST SAID THAT AS TO THE THIRTY
FOR THE OF THOSE SOLDIERS THEY
WERE INJURED THAT THEY JUST
HAVE MINOR HEADACHES AND THAT
THAT'S NOT REALLY A BIG DEAL.
SO I YOU DON'T ACTUALLY NEED TO
COMMENT I DON'T WANT TO GO DOWN
THAT PATH BUT WE MIGHT SEE SOME
OF THOSE THIRTY FOUR. NO DOUBT
NO DOUBT- I ALSO KNOW ON PAGE
NINETY ONE- IT SAYS CALIFORNIA
IS EIGHT POINT 3% OF THE
NATION'S TOTAL VETERAN
POPULATION BUT 29% OF THE
NATION'S HOMELESS VETERANS WHAT
WHY IS THAT AT WELL THAT'S A
GOOD QUESTION AND 52% OF THE
NATION'S ON SHELTERED VETERANS.
TO MAKE IT WORSE THERE ARE NO
HOMELESS VETERANS IN NORTH
DAKOTA NORTHERN VERMONT
NORTHERN MAINE. FOR OBVIOUS
REASONS- OTHER STATES IN THE
LAST THREE YEARS- I'M TAKING A
VIRGINIA CONNECTICUT AND MAYBE
RHODE ISLAND SOLVED PUBLICLY
ANNOUNCED THEY SOLVE THEIR
VETERAN HOME HOUSING
HOMELESSNESS SITUATION. BECAUSE
CONNECTICUT HAD. THREE HUNDRED.
THREE AND WE HAVE LAST COUNT
LIVE IN SOUTH BECAUSE- VETERANS.
YOU THINK THERE. TO MOVING
TOWARDS CLIMATE CONDITIONS
SCARY STITCH. AND THAT WE-
MENTION TODAY AND I HAVE. EXT
FOR IS THAT WHILE THE VETERANS
OF CURRENT CONFLICTS THEIR
DISABILITY RATE IS GOING UP AS
THE GENERAL POPULATION GOES
DOWN. CALIFORNIA VETERANS ARE
MORE DISABLED THAN THE VETERANS
OF ANY OTHER STATE. WAS IT
BECAUSE OF SOME I DON'T SOMEONE
HERE IN FOR A MEETING. OF JUST
I DON'T KNOW WHETHER THEY MICRO.
OR AYE I DON'T HAVE AN ANSWER
FOR THAT. LASKO UP OVER THE IN
PREP SO CAN COME BACK A LITTLE
LATER ON IS THAT WE HAVE A BAY.
HOME YOU YOU LOOK AT THE
DIAGRAM AND YOU WONDER. WHY WE
HAVE HOMES IN CERTAIN PLACES
WHERE WE DO HAVE HOMES. OF ANY
IN YOU MENTION CRY TO YOUR FOR
NEW HOMES- AND ALSO THE
CHALLENGES WE HAVE IN BARSTOW.
FILLING BEDS BECAUSE OF THE-
MANY ISSUES SURROUNDING BARS
THE WHAT WHAT DO YOU TH ARE YOU
THINKING ABOUT ANY PARTICULAR
LOCATION HERE FOR A FOR A NEW
HOME. NO I'M NOT AT THE- SURE
GOES BACK TO IF I CAN USE THE
ANALOGY TO A MONOPOLY BOARD IF
I COULD BE. ALL THE HOTELS AND
HOUSES ON CLEAN. NOW NO AS YON
PHIL. WAS BILL A HUNDRED THIRTY
FIVE YEARS AGO SO THAT CITY OF
SAN FRANCISCO HAVE A- HUMANE
WAY OF TREATING THE VETERANS OF
THE CIVIL WAR. THEY BOTTOM
SEVEN HUNDRED ACRES OUT THERE
IT WAS A WORKING FARM THEY ALL
WENT UP THERE AND THEY WEREN'T
ON THE STREETS OF SAN
FRANCISCO. WITH THEIR HATS IN
THEIR HAND ONCE WE COME THE
EXPRESSION HANDICAPPED BY THE
WAY- YEAH. THE MADE SENSE THEN.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE- OF
CALIFORNIA TODAY WITH OUR
POPULATION CENTERS WHERE THEY
ARE AND WHERE OUR VETERANS.
POPULATIONS ARE THE BAY AREA-
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS IN LA
COUNTY THE INLAND EMPIRE
AROUND- MARCH AIR FORCE BASE.
AND SAN DIEGO THE NAVY
PRESENTS. IT I WISH I COULD
JUST PLUG THEM UP FOR WHERE
THEY ARE RIGHT PUT. RIGHT
SUMMER BILL RELATIVE LAST YEARS
BUT WHAT WHAT THE YOUNG THE I.
FELLOW. I WOULD MAKE SENSE TO
CAN MOVING THAT BUT BECAUSE-
THE REPLACE. BUILDING OF THE
THREE OLDEST BUILDINGS THERE IS
THE NUMBER ONE ON THE NATIONAL
V. A.'S. NEEDS LIST
CALIFORNIA'S NUMBER ONE TO HAVE
THOSE THREE BUILDINGS REPLACED-
IF THEY'RE GONNA GIVE US A
SUBSTANTIAL. HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO BUILD A
NEW NURSING STATE OF THE ART
FACILITY THERE. THERE ISN'T ANY
WAY I CAN ABANDON SO FOR.
EMOTIONAL REASONS HISTORICAL
REASONS AND IF THERE'S A
ANCIENT CEMETERY ON THAT
PROPERTY I DON'T THINK WE'RE
EVER GOING EVEN THOUGH IT
DOESN'T MEET ANY MY CRITERIA.
RIGHT WE'RE NOT GONNA THAT
CAMPUS WE COULD YOU. RIGHT TO
CAN RE LOW. WHY ARE STILL. A
BAR SO OR ARE I SAY IF WHAT IF
THE FED Vì ã. WANTS MY HOME
AT THE WAY A WESTELL CAMPUS TO
ALLOW THEM CREATE THEIR MASTER
PLAN ALL OF THAT. IF THEY MAKE
THE OLYMPIAN EQUAL FACILITY IN
THE FERNANDO VALLEY UP AND
SUPPORT THE AREA. IT WILL I
WOULD TAKE IT IN HIGH BECAUSE
IT WAS MY EMPLOYMENT I KNOW I
AM GET THE WHOLE IS A- THEY DO
NOT MEET YOUR- SO THAT THE
QUESTION IS. ARE YOU THINKING
ABOUT OTHER LOCATIONS FOR THEIR
NEW HOMES OR RELOCATING SOME
LISTING ON SU THEIR LOCATION
AND IF. OUR WHAT. SO YOU THINK
IN A THANK. IF I. GET MOVES ARE
SO MY WITH IT UP IN. THE CITY
IT ASIDE. SOLVE ALL MY- IN A
BEATS OFF CONCURS THAT. THE. S.
THANK YOU AND YOU ACTUALLY
ADDRESS SOME OF THE QUESTIONS I
HAD BECAUSE I KNOW IN PAST
HEARINGS WE'VE ALWAYS TALKED
ABOUT THE WAIT LIST. AND THE
WAIT LIST FOR SKILLED NURSING.
RIGHT AND YOU KNOW AND THEN
THIS REPORT YOU TALK ABOUT HOW.
THE NUMBER OF VETERANS ACTUALLY
DECREASING BUT THEN WE HAVE
EIGHT HOMES BUT THEY'RE NOT ALL
BEING. ALSO USED AT PEAK
EFFICIENCY I GUESS IS A NICE
WAY TO SAY IT. SUCH WATER CAN
YOU COMMENT ON. THE WAIT LIST
THE NEEDS AND HOW WE'RE
ADDRESSING THAT IN THE MASTER
PLAN AND- AND MAYBE YOU KNOW
THAT KIND OF LEADS TO WHETHER
WE'RE GOING TO RELOCATE OR- YOU
HOMES. FOR JUST COMMENT ON TAT
SERVICE COUPLE TIME YOU'RE
CHIME IN TO SERVE. THE
POPULATION IS GOING DOWN. BUT
THEY'RE JUST A- RAY ARE GOING
UP THE CROSS THIS AND- SHE-
WHICH- LOOKING AT THE NEW. THAT
WE- THE NEED THAT I SEE COMING
IS FORCED NURSING ASSISTED
LIVING MUCH NURSING AND MEMORY.
WE DON'T THOSE OTHER TO LOVE OF
CARE ANYMORE ONLY X. OF SIR
NUMBER OF OUR HOMES WE CAN
THESE FACED OUT. OF THE FOR WE
WOULD LOSE WITH THE LOSS OF A
DOMICILIARY WAS A TWENTY FOUR
DOLLARS A DAY FORTY DOLLARS A
DAY IF COULD COMES NO WHERE
NEAR THE COST OF CARE. IF WE
STARTED PRIVATIZING AS WE DID
WITH LEGISLATION THAT YOU
HELPED US WITH A FEW YEARS AGO.
PRIORITIZING VETERANS WITH
GREATER THAN 70% DISABILITY THE
FEDERAL REIMBURSEMENT MORRISON
COVERS OUR COST OF CARE THIS IS
HOW NEW YORK STATE MAKES A
PROFIT ON ITS BETTER HOMES. IN
WHAT WE ONLY RECOUP. THIRTY
FOUR FORTY FOR SINCE THAT OF
OUR COST OF CARE. SO IT WOULD
INTERSECTING LINE GOING ON I'M
AT THE LEVELS OF. I SEE THAT
WE'VE GOT TOO MANY OF A KIND
BAD WE DO NEED NOT NEARLY
ENOUGH TO A TSUNAMI IS GOING TO
HIT US IN TEN TO FIFTEEN YEARS
WHEN. WHEN VIDAK VETERANS OF
CURRENT CONFLICT COM AT US WITH
SEVERE DISABILITIES AND ALL THE
EFFECTS OF THE BEHAVIORAL
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES. US THAT
THEY SUFFERED BY EXPOSURE OF
THEIR BRAINS TO THE MODERN
BATTLEFIELD AND WE'RE NOT GOING
TO WE'RE NEVER GONNA HAVE
ENOUGH BEDS NEVER NEVER NEVER
BUT I WANT TO DO THE BEST I CAN
WITH WHAT YOU GIVE ME. I HAD
THE ONE AT THE HOUSE ACTUALLY.
PRETTY MUCH EVERYTHING ELSE CAN
SAY. AND OF. I'D JUST BY TO GO
BACK YOU BRIEF MEN THE HOW AND
HOME PRO AND HOW DO THAT WORK
YOU YOUR TALKING YOU'RE PLANNED
ELIMINATE DA A CARE THAT IS A
PROGRAM YOU WHEN YOU WHEN YOU
TALK ABOUT THE HOMELESS A
CRISIS THAT WE HAVE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA VH H. P. HAS DONE A
LOT TO REDUCE THE NUMBER OF
VETS AND THAT IS THE ONLY
PERCENT OF THE POPULATION IN
CALIFORNIA THAT IS ACTUALLY
DECREASING AND SO WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT. HELLO THOMAS CARE. HOW
DOES VH H. P. FIT INTO THAT AND
BUT I JUST WANT TO ADD THAT YOU
MENTIONED THAT THE NORTH DAKOTA
HAS ZERO HOMELESS HAD THAT
THAT'S- BECAUSE THEY REALLY
WILD THE WEATHER IS TERRIBLE
THERE. BUT WE DO HAVE A COUNTY
HERE THAT HAS WHAT THEY CALL
FUNCTIONALLY ZERO HOMELESS VETS
AND PARTIALLY BECAUSE OF THE H.
H. P. AND THE FEDERAL MONEY
THAT'S AVAILABLE AND I KNOW I
WAS AT A HEARING IN. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER OF PETRIE-NORRIS IS. AND
THERE WERE ON TO HOME VETS ALL
SO. IT IS CONCERNED THAT I
DON'T SEE AT THAT MUCH- I DON'T
KNOW IF THERE'S INTEREST RIGHT
NOW IN OF AND CONTINUING THE V.
H. H. P. PROGRAM CONTINUING TO
FUND BECAUSE THE FUNDS ARE
GOING TO BE RUNNING SHORT. SO
I'M GONNA PASS SISTER FOR TOO
MUCH INTEREST SAY THAT WE
PRESENTED YOU TODAY A MASTER
PLAN ON THE VETERANS HOMES AND
NOT THE ENTIRE CONTINUITY
CONTINUAL OF CARE- FROM
EMERGING KERR TRANSITIONAL
SUPPORT OF. THROUGH OUR FARM
AND HOME OWNERS. PROGRAM SO IF
YOU. AVAILABLE ON SURE SO YOU
KNOW SORRY I AM DEFINITELY A
HUGE. OF EACH BE AMIDST BOUNCE
A WAS SOMETHING ELSE TERRIBLY
FAMILIAR WITH WE STARTED TO
THIS. CA YOU KNOW WE GET IN
ABOUT IN WE'RE BOTH ON THAT
COMES. UP BUT YOU KNOW IN IN A
WITH. VETERANS SERVICE OR INS
CHINS BEING WITH VH STAY
GETTING ABOUT SENSE OF THE THIS.
THAT ARE YEAH REALLY. THAT THAT
REALLY THE- POLICE SEE IT CAN
THE PAST THE BEST TOOL WE IN
OUR TO FOR DEALING HOME THERE.
A THAT IS IT'S CAN ADD TO STAY
BETWEEN WHAT. BY UP THE
INDEPENDENT LIVING THE VETERANS
HOMES FOR SO. ARE DONE LEARY
PRO. WET LIKE THE SECTOR
MENTIONS REALLY DOES. FOR
PEOPLE. PRETTY MUCH NO NEEDS
IT'S JEFF. IT JUST ROOM IN
HERE'S THE APARTMENT. AND
THAT'S THAT'S NOT REALLY WHAT
HOW VH PEAS OPERATES SO CAN
FEATURES PEAS ARE FOCUSED ON
OBVIOUSLY THEY THERE'S A
HOUSING COMPONENT THEY THEY
WANNA MAKE SURE THEY HAVE- AT
HAVE THE PROGRAM HOUSING SECURE
HOUSING. BUT ALSO THEY MAKE
SURE THAT THEY HAVE ACCESS TO
VOCATIONAL PROGRAMS AND- A
SUBSIDIES- PROGRAMS AS A NEED
IT'S- COUNT JOB COUNSELLING
EVERS ALL SORTS OF OTHER
SERVICES- THAT ARE NOT REALLY
PART OF HOW THAT THE DINOSAURS
OPERATE. BUT THE OTHER KEY PART
TO IT UNDER THE KEY PART IS THE
LOCATION SO THE VETERANS HOME
TO HAVE DOMICILIARY. ON THE
OTHER ONES WITH NO DEMAND ON
THOSE ARE THE YON PHIL AND-
BARSTOW HOMES. THOSE HOMES
LIKELY NOT VERY CONDUCIVE TO
TRYING TO OPERATE A HOMELESS
HOMELESSNESS SUPPORT PROGRAM
BECAUSE A THERE'S NOT A LOT
HOMELESS VETERANS IN THAT AREA-
THEY DON'T SEEM TO MIGRATE TO
THE MIDDLE OF THE OF THE HIGH
DESERT OR OR- OR WINE COUNTRY-
BUT ALSO. AS BE THAT THE OTHER
SUPPORTING MISTER I THE GENERAL
PREVENTER SO WHAT. THERE WITH A
YOU KNOW THAT'S KIND. IT'S KIND
OF THE END OF EITHER SIR I
GUESS YOU KNOW THE COME THE
VETERANS HOME. THE INTO THE
DUMBEST. GENERALLY THEY'LL
THEY'LL KIND OF STAY IN THE FOR
THE THEIR LIFE A THEY MIGHT
WORK TO HAVE TO A HIGHER LEVEL
OF CARE. AND RESERVATIONS P. A
BIG PART OF THE V. H. P. IS TO.
IS TO GET THEM THOSE ADDITIONAL
SERVICES AND HELP THEM. GET A
JOB WE INTEGRATE- THOSE TYPES
OF THINGS SO IT'S BATES MEANT
MORE TO BE A- YEAH. SHORT TERM
I GUESS. AND THIS OPERATE
PHRASING BUT- YOU KNOW
HOPEFULLY TO HELP THEM I REALLY
GAINED. IN THE COMMUNITY SO.
AND I'M SAYING A LOT THINGS YOU
OBVIOUSLY ALREADY NOW BUT AT
THE HELM. BUT HOPEFULLY THAT
KIND OF MAKES CLEAR THERE'S
THERE IS A DISTINCTION THE
POPULATION SERVE SO. WHEN YOU
LOOK AT THE DOMICILIARY. IN IN
THE NURSING HOME JUMPER
BARSTOW. GENERALLY THE PEOPLE
WHO ARE INTERESTED IN
DOMICILIARY. DON'T QUALIFY
BECAUSE THEY HAVE CARE NEEDS
THAT A MORE SIGNIFICANT- OR
THEY NEED THIS OTHER SERVICES.
AND THE PEOPLE WHO SHOULD
QUALIFY. WE DON'T HAVE NEEDS
ARE GENERALLY NOT APPLYING
THEY'RE NOT INTERESTED SO
THAT'S KIND OF INTERESTING SO
THERE'S NO A WHOLE LOT OF
OVERLAP THAT WE SEE BETWEEN
THOSE TWO POPULATIONS. RIGHT
AND THEN- AS YOU MOVE TOWARD I
MEAN POTENTIALLY MOVE TOWARD
THESE SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES ARE OR MORE- BEDS
FOR- MEMORY CARE. OF DO YOU SEE
THE TOTAL NUMBER AND- THE
ELIMINATING SLOWLY-
DOMICILIARY. DO YOU SEE THE
NUMBER OF TOTAL THAT'S GOING
DOWN AT THE FACILITIES.
PROBABLY PROBABLY BUT THE BEDS
THAT WERE LEUCINE ONCE AGAIN
ARE ONES THAT GIVE US VERY
LITTLE AND FEDERAL
REIMBURSEMENT. AND THOSE PEOPLE
CAN IF YOU IF YOU'LL CONSIDER
THE V. H. H. P. HOMELESS UP
POPULATION AND THE- LONG TERM
CARE THAT WE PROVIDE OUR HOMES
AS VENN DIAGRAMS THERE'S AN
OVERLAP. AND WE'RE ABLE BY A
WARM HAND OFF PROCESS TO TAKE
THOSE FEW PEOPLE IN THE V. H.
H. P. PROGRAMS WHO THEN REQUIRE
LONG TERM CARE IN NURSING HOMES
WE CAN TAKE THE MAN NOT
EVERYBODY BY FAR IN AND OUR VH
H. P. HOUSING NEEDS LONG TERM
CARE. RIGHT THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PETRIE-NORRIS AND THEN I WILL
TURN IT BACK OVER HIS SENATOR
ARCH LET OF YOU KNOW I JUST
OKAY OKAY AND JUST PICKING UP
ON ON THAT QUESTION IN TERMS OF
THAT WHETHER OR NOT E FORECAST
NUMBER OF PETS TO GO DOWN AND
YOU SAID PROBABLY I'M JUST IN
THE EMPLOYEES AT PICKING UP ON
AT THE CHAIRS QUESTION AROUND
WHETHER OR NOT WE WOULD EXPECT
THE NUMBER OF BEDS TO GO DOWN
YOUR ANSWER IS PROBABLY. SU I'M
LOOKING AT PAGE NINETY FOUR IN
YOUR SUMMARY SO THAT THESE
PRODUCTION SAY THAT THE ODD
NUMBER OF. RESIDENTIAL CARE
BEDS ARE PROJECTED TO GO DOWN
FROM THIRTY THREE THOUSAND
TODAY TO NINETEEN THOUSAND AND
TWENTY FORTY. AND THAT NURSING
HOME CARE IS EXPECTED TO GO
DOWN FROM FOURTEEN THOUSAND
TODAY. TO EIGHT THOUSAND AND
TWENTY FORTY. ARE THESE IS IN
MY READING THESE NUMBERS
CORRECTLY ARE THESE ARE
PROJECTIONS FOR THE NUMBER OF
BEDS THAT WE NEED TO PLAN FOR
OVER THE COURSE OF THE NEXT
TWENTY YEARS SO- THIS THIS WAS
DEVELOPED AS IT SO THERE THERE
ARE A LOT OF LIMITATIONS IN
VETERAN SPECIFIC DATA- AND WHAT
WE IDENTIFY WHICH IS BASICALLY
WHAT THE IN. THE AT ALL CHAPTER
FOUR IS ABOUT HIS UNDERSTANDING
THAT- YOU CAN'T YOU CAN'T TAKE
A NON VETERAN. OF A CERTAIN AGE
CERTAIN GENEROUS CETERA AND
TAKE A VETERAN WITH ALL THE
SAME CHARACTERISTICS AND ASSUME
THAT THE CARE NEEDS ARE
SIMILAR- SO THIS DATA THAT'S ON
HERE- THIS IS A- IN MY OPINION
VERY LOW ESTIMATE- IS SUING
THAT'S- IF VETERANS HAD THE
SAME. CARE NEEDS AS NON
VETERANS THIS WOULD BE THE
FLOOR THIS WE HOW MANY-
VETERANS WHO EXPECT ME CARE. ON
THE RALLY IS BECAUSE WE
RECOGNIZE A VETERANS HAVE
GREATER CARE NEEDS IN GENERAL
MORE LIKELY NEED LONG TERM CARE
THAT THEY'RE TRUE NUMBERS
PROBABLY HIGHER THAN IT. IS
OUTSIDE THEIR TABLE THAT HAS
THOSE PROJECTIONS SOMEWHERE BUT
WE DON'T HAVE SPECIFIC PROJECTS
ON THE AND THAT'S THAT THAT
SPEAKS TO THE LIMITATIONS ON
GETTING VETERAN SPECIFIC LONG
TERM CAREDATA. I'M SO AGAIN WE
CAN RECOGNIZE THAT SAYS THIS IS
A MINIMUM- IT'S GOING TO BE
SOME NUMBER HIGHER THAN THIS-
BUT EITHER WAY IF YOU LOOK AT
NINETEEN THOUSAND HOW MANY
RESIDENTS CARE TWENTY FORTY
EIGHT THOUSAND NAY OF NON OF
NURSING HOME CARE AND TWENTY
FORTY- CONCERN WILL HAVE TWENTY
THREE HUNDRED- AT TWENTY.
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY BEDS
OBVIOUSLY WE'RE NOT WE WOULD BE
ABLE TO COME EIGHT- ALL THESE
VETERANS REGARDLESS SO THAT THE
REALITY IS WHAT WE'VE- AS
SACRAMENTO WERE WERE HOPING TO
DO IS. SHIFT OUR FOCUS SHIP THE
RESOURCES MAKE SURE WE'RE WERE
WERE USED FOR USING THE
RESOURCES THE BEST CAN AND FOLK.
ON A ON VETERANS. PROBABLY JUST
TO GET THEM A- WHICH IS ALMOST.
DOES THIS TIE SEARCH CAN.
GETTING I'M IN THE OTHER THING
THAT WE'VE WE PRIORITIZE
PREVIOUS YEARS WITH ALLEGE.
ASSISTANCE OKAY AND THEN. I WON
THING I WOULD FIND HELPFUL
MIGHT ARE EXIST IS SOME KIND OF
ROUGH. PROJECTION OF A YOU
THINK KIND OF THE DEMAND REALLY
IS GOING TO BE OVER THE COURSE
OF THE NEXT. TEN YEARS AND THEN
YOU GIVEN THE RESOURCES WE HAVE
HOW MUCH OF THAT DEMAND YOU
ACTUALLY THINK WE'RE GOING TO
BE ABLE. TO MEET BECAUSE I
THINK UNDERSTANDING. THAT
DISCONNECT AND NOT. HOW BIG
THAT FUNDING SHORTFALL IS
REALLY IMPORTANT AS WE AS WE
THINK ABOUT PLANNING FOR THE
NEXT. TEN TWENTY YEARS. RIGHT
US SENATOR ARCH LETTER YOU HAD
A QUESTION YES. ONE OF MY. SITE
VISITS THAT I'VE GOT PLAN IS TO
GO WITH THE SECRETARY TO
BARSTOW AND TAKE A LOOK I WAS
THERE- THEIR YOUNG SHOWS YOU
KNOW BUT WHEN YOU MENTION THE
NUMBER OF BEDS THAT ARE EMPTY
AT BARSTOW I THINK- THE GENERAL
PUBLIC THE PERCEPTION IS IF
THERE'S AN EMPTY BED ANYWHERE.
THAT A VETERAN CAN COME TO- AND
WE HAVE THAT BAD AND IT SHAME
ON US IF WE'RE NOT FEELING SO
MY CONCERN ABOUT IS AN OUTREACH
PROGRAM I MEAN IF YOU WENT OUT
THERE ROLL UP YOUR SLEEVES OR
WHOEVER THE STAFF AND SAID
WE'RE GOING TO FILL. BARSTOW I
MEAN WHAT I MEAN YOU MENTIONED
HOW MANY BEDS ARE EMPTY. THREE
HUNDRED TO A ABOUT ABOUT TWO
HUNDRED. TO ABOUT TWO HUNDRED
ON BUDGETED AND THEN- AD BUT
TOTAL COULDN'T BUDGE ON BUDGET
AND JUST VACANT BEDS IS ABOUT
TWO HUNDRED TWENTY OR SO WELL
ABOUT TWO HUNDRED TWENTY BEDS.
THAT THAT POINT IT RIGHT YES
WHEN RIGHT NOW IF YOU TALK TO
THE AVERAGE. A PERSON IN THE
STREET- WHEN YOU INTERVIEW AND
WHAT DO YOU THINK ABUT. THE
SITUATION ABOUT HOMELESS
VETERANS AND THEY SAY THAT.
IT'S JUST A SHAME AT THE WE AS
A COUNTRY NEED TO TAKE CARE OF
VETERANS OR WE'VE GOT. TWO
HUNDRED TWENTY EMPTY BEDS SO I
I'M ASKING YOU TO LAY OUT IF
YOU CAN SOME OUTREACH PROGRAMS
EITHER GET VETERANS. THAT ARE
WAITING AND SOME OF THE OTHER
COMMUNITIES UP AND DOWN THE
STATE OR ACTUALLY WORK WITH THE
COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES. DO
SOMETHING WE'VE GOT TO DO
SOMETHING PRO ACTIVELY. TO FILL
THESE BEDS IN THE AND I JUST
THINK THAT- WE JUST DESPERATELY
NEED TO DO THAT. THE OTHER
THING I DO. AGREE WITH YOU
THAT. OBTAINING PSYCHIATRISTS
PSYCHOLOGISTS SOCIAL WORKERS
THAT ARE NEEDED NOT JUST THAT
IN BARSTOW BUT ACROSS TE
BOARD. IS STOLEN AN IMPORTANT.
AND I DID LEARN THIS SAID AT
YON PHIL. THAT THE WORK FORCE
IS SO FAR OUT THAT IT'S VERY
VERY DIFFICULT TO BRING A MAN.
QUALITY IN THE- WITH THE
TRAINING AND SKILL. TO WORK AT
THE FACILITY I UNDERSTAND THAT.
YOU MAY HAVE THAT SAME PROBLEM.
THERE IN BARSTOW BUT WE'VE GOT
TO BE ABLE TO OFFSET IT YOU
NEED TO COME TO US. SO WE CAN
GO TO THE GOVERNOR AND
EVERYWHERE ELSE. IF IT'S IF
IT'S A LACK OF PAY. IF THAT'S
WHAT MIGHT BE IN IT IT WAS A
SITUATION. COULD IT BE HOUSING
SHOULD WE BE BUILDING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING ON THE
PROPERTY. THERE IN YONGE FILLED
THEIR IN BARSTOW SO WE CAN HAVE
THESE PROFESSIONALS. NOT ONLY
WORK AT THE FACILITY BUT LIVE
NEAR THE- LAKE. SO GIVE ME SOME
IDEA WOULD YOU THINK YOU'RE
GOING TO DO WITH THIS. THE
PERSON. WHO GO SO AT WELL FIRST
OFF SO WE DO HAVE SOME
RECOMMENDATIONS ABOUT- ABOUT AT
A YOUNG FROM BARSTOW HOMES- SO
IT'S A SPEAKING TO YOU MENTION
FOR A HOUSING OUT FOR THAT IS
ONE OF THE RECOMMENDATIONS THAT
WE TRY TO FIND A WAY TO BRING
IN AFFORDABLE HOUSING ON THE
CAMPUS ON WHICH WOULD BE A
BENEFIT FOR STAFF- BENEFITS FOR
RESIDENTS AND BENEFIT FOR THE
COMMUNITY IN GENERAL SITE IS
SOMETHING THAT'S A MAJOR ISSUE
AND THAT IS SOMETHING THAT-
IT'S ON TGS IS- LIST OF STATE
PROPERTIES THAT THAT COULD BE-
IDEAL FOR A FULL HOUSING SO
OBVIOUSLY. THE DETAILS WITH
YOUR TO THAT PROCESS BUT THAT
THAT'S THAT'S A SPECIFIC- ITEM
THAT WE REALLY THINK IS
CRITICAL BECAUSE IF YOU'RE
LOOKING AT. IF YOU LOOK AT THE
LONG TERM FUTURE THE CAMPUS.
THE HOUSING AFFORDABILITY IS A
MAJOR. IT'S GONNA BE A MAJOR
CHALLENGE. IN PERPETUITY- SO
THE MORE THAT WE CAN. PROVIDE
ON SITE HOUSING- AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. ON THE BETTER OFF
WE'RE GOING TO BE AND IT'S ALSO
A MAJOR ISSUE DURING AN
EMERGENCY IF WE ARE TO HAVE
STAFF THERE- THAT'S- REALLY
BEEN. A HUGE HELP TO US IN THE
LAST NAM. OF LAST YEAR'S AND
CELEBRITIES WITHOUT SOIT IS IT
IS A MAJOR ISSUE- IN ON ON THE
WAGES- AND NOT IT'S PROBABLY
NOT ANSWER. FOLKS LIKE TO HEAR
BUT- WE DO HAVE LIMITATIONS ON
WHAT WE CAN DISCUSS RELATED
LABOR AND BARGAINING ON THOSE
TYPES OF THINGS- BUT THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT- IN. WE'VE BEEN
LOOKING INTERNALLY A KIND
WHATEVER WHAT OUR OPTIONS ARE.
SO YOU KNOW BUT I DO WANT TO
SAY. YOU KNOW WE HAVE. WE HAVE
REALLY REALLY GOOD STAFF ANY OF
THEM ARE STILL I THINK. I THINK
GIVEN THE- YOU KNOW GIVEN GIVEN
THE CHALLENGES GIVEN HOW FAR
SOME PEOPLE HAVE TO WORKERS
SOME LIMITATIONS- IT IS. YOUR
IT IS REALLY HARD TO RECRUIT
FOR A LOT OF POSITIONS. BUT A
HAND YOU KNOW SOME THE PAPER
TRUTH. THE REALLY REALLY
AMAZING THEY'RE IN THERE FOR
THE LONG HAUL- IN BOTH HOMES
ARE THERE FIVE STAR FACILITIES
RIGHT NOW AND THAT'S- YOU KNOW
YOU HAVE TO HAVE A GOOD TEAM
TO. DO THAT SO YOU KNOW WE ARE.
WE CAN CERTAINLY IMPROVE THAT
PROCESS I THINK THERE'S SOME
OPTIONS LIKE SOMEONE BEING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND ON THE
APPLE CAMPUS AND IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE OF LET ME FOLLOW UP WITH
THIS WALK US THROUGH THE
ELIGIBILITY. OF A VETERAN TO
GET INTO OUR ONE OF OUR HOMES-
I UNDERSTAND THAT IF THERE WAS
A VETERAN WHO SEEKING- TO LIVE
AT ONE OF THE HOMES WHATEVER DO
YOU NEED TO RUN HIM THROUGH THE
VA SYSTEM. SO THEY CAN BE
CHANNELED. TO US WITH THE STATE
OR CAN WE EVALUATE THEM
OURSELVES. A YES SO WE CAN WE
CAN EVALUATE THEM SO OUR
SELVES- UNIT. RIGHT MY DEFINITE
OVER ONE MY NAME IS BETH
WYSHYNSKI AN ASSISTANT DEPUTY
SECRETARY OF VETERANS HOMES I
CALVET- WE HAVE- SPELLED OUT IN
STE IN MILITARY VETERANS CODE
WITH ELIGIBILITY REQUIREMENTS
ARE AND- THERE THAT THE PERSON
BE A CALIFORNIA RESIDENT- THAT
THEY HAVE BY A- SERVE IN THE-
IN THE- IN THE MILITARY AND
DISCHARGED UNDER- CONDITIONS
OTHER THAN DISHONORABLE. THAN
AND THAT THEY BE ELIGIBLE FOR.
CARE THROUGH THE VA THAT WHICH
IS NOT TO SAY THAT THEY HAVE TO
SPEND A LOT OF TIME LIVING IN A
OF THE A PROGRAM IF THAT'S WHAT
YOU'RE WONDERING ABOUT AND THEN
COME TO US AND THROUGH THAT
ROUTE. THEY JUST HAVE TO BE
ELIGIBLE THAT THE VA HAS TO
CERTIFY THAT THEY'RE ELIGIBLE
TO RECEIVE CARE IN STATE
VETERANS HOME AS PART OF THE
PARTNERSHIP THAT WE HAVE. WITH
THE VA WHERE THEY PROVIDE
CERTAIN TYPES OF CARE ACUTE
CARE TO THE CLINICS AND SOME
DIFFERENT KINDS OF PROGRAMMING
AND SPECIALTY CARE. AND THEN WE
PROVIDE THE LONG TERM CARE WITH
THEM WITH THEIR SUPPORT YOUR
MOM PRETTY YEMEN. AND IN OTHER
WAYS- SO THEY THEY DO HAVE TO
MEET THE ELIGIBILITY AS FAR AS
THE VA IS CONCERNED AND THERE
AREN'T THEIR DEFINITION AND
THEIR PROGRAMMING. BUT IT'S
JUST A- IT'S A MATTER OF THEM
VALUE WAITING IN AND AGREED TO
THAT AND THE PERSON BEING AND
ROLLED DOWN THROUGH THAT
PROCESS IT'S NOT A LENGTHY STAY
IN A VA PROGRAM THE CIRCLE I
JUST WANTED TO BE PUT ON THE
TABLE RIGHT NOW THAT. WE
APPRECIATE YOUR WORK WHICH
SECTARIANS AFTER NO DOUBT BUT I
GUESS IT'S THE ANXIETY THAT WE
HAVE BECAUSE IN EVERYONE OF OUR
DISTRICTS EVERY SINGLE ONE OF
US. AND WHEN WE GO BACK THE
FIRST THING THAT WHAT WHAT DO
YOU DO THE HOMELESS AND WHEN
THERE'S VETERANS OUT RIGHT
OUTSIDE HIS DOOR. THAT MIGHT BE
ABLE TO SAY IF BUT WOULD I FIND
PLACE WHETHER BEYONCE WILL A
WEATHERED IN BARS. I WOULD
CERTAINLY TAKE A LOOK AT IT SO
I THINK THE PUBLIC TIONS
PROGRAM TO YOU MIGHT HAVE THE
OUR- PRO MIGHT. YEAH THE
RELEASE IT UP BECAUSE- WE'VE
GOT AN ANSWER TO A KIDS TO. YOU
NEED AN- TO VETERAN SHOW CAN
GET OFF THE STREET. AND GET
HELP AS YOU KNOW. I BELIEVE
THERE'S ELLA. TO THE OMELESS.
ONE OF COURSE ONE OF THE JUST
LOST HER JOB AND- AND THEY HAVE
ISSUES AT WORK OR HOME- THE
OTHER. IS THE ONE WHO IS REALLY
TRULY MENTALLY ILL WHO NEEDS
HELP. AND THE LAST ONE WAS
PUTTING SOMETHING IN THEIR
VEINS AND DRINKING AND SO ON.
AND THAT ONE MAY NOT FIT FOR
US. BUT CERTAINLY THE VETERANS
WHO. HAVE PTSD WHO- JUST. NEED
THAT HELP DESPERATELY WE'VE GOT
TO FIND A MAN GET TO BUT- A LOT
OF WHAT YOU JUST SAID POINTS TO
THE SUCCESS OF THE- OF THE V.
H. H. P. PROGRAM. THEY SHOULD.
DEPARTMENT LET ME JUST A LITTLE
BIT TO THAT BECAUSE THERE IS A
LOT OF SECRET SAUCE IN THE
SUCCESS OF THAT VETERANS
HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS
PREVENTION PROGRAM WE'RE ABOUT
HALFWAY THROUGH IT WE'VE HAD
FOR PHASES WE'VE GIVEN OUT
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN
CONTRACTS ON AVERAGE EACH YEAR
WE JUST PUT OUT THE FIFTH NO
FOR RESULTS WILL START COMING
IN THIS YEAR WE SPENT THREE
HUNDRED OF THE SIX HUNDRED
MILLION WITH THAT MONEY WE HAVE
BUILT. ALL OVER THE STATE I
WANT TO SAY IN ALMOST EVERY
COUNTY BUT ALL OVER THE STATE-
WE BUILT TWENTY TWO HUNDRED
TWENTY FOUR HUNDRED UNITS FOR
HOMELESS VETERANS AND WHEN THAT
PROGRAMMING SAUCE IT'S FUNDS-
IT WE WILL HAVE BUILT CLOSE TO
FIVE THOUSAND UNITS PART OF THE
SECRET SAUCE WE'LL OF SPEND SIX
HUNDRED MILLION TO DATE. HAVING
SPENT. THREE HUNDRED MILLION WE
HAVE BROUGHT IN. BY TAPPING
INTO FEDERAL STATE COMMUNITY
MONIES FOUR HUNDRED AND SIXTY
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS THAT WENT
TO THE CONSTRUCTION. EVERYONE
OF THESE PROGRAMS HAS EITHER
CLOSE TO IT OR ON SITE. A CASE
MANAGER WHY ARE THOSE VETERANS
HOMELESS FOR ALL THE REASONS
YOU JUST MENTIONED SENATOR.
THERE SOMEBODY THERE TO HELP
THEM WITH THEIR JOBTRAINING IF
THAT'S WHAT THEY NEED. THEIR
SUBSTANCE ABUSE THEIR FINANCIAL
LITERACY WHAT JOB TRENT
WHATEVER IT IS THAT CAUSE THEM
TO BE HOMELESS. IT'S ALL TIED
UP INTO THAT PROGRAM. IT'S VERY
SUCCESSFUL I THINK THAT THAT
WILL PROBABLY GO. THE VHS PER
WILL GO FARTHER IN HELPING THAT
POPULATION THAN THE VETERANS
HOMES WILL. CHIU THANK AND MY
QUESTION ALL RIGHT AND THEN WE
HAVE OF A OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
VOEPEL FOLLOWED BY AS A SENATOR
ROTH. SO. MADAM CHAIR MR
SENATOR CHAIR NEVER QUITE SURE
HOW TO ADDRESS THE SENATOR AND
HIS CARE YEAH CULTURE. ALL
RIGHT I'M GONNA PUT MY VETERANS
HAD ON. DID TOWARDS VIETNAM I
WAS A PROFESSIONAL TARGET. NO
BIG HERO PROFESSIONAL TARGET SO.
MISTER SECRETARY. I'VE READ IN
DEPTH YOUR REPORT IT IS 85%
PERFECT OKAY YOU DIDN'T GET 15%
BECAUSE I DIDN'T THANK YOU
FOUNDED. I MEAN YOU'RE IN
CHARGE OF A GIGANTIC WEIRDO
MACHINE THAT RUNS ON ITS OWN
AND YOU'RE LIKE THE- INCHING
CAR THIRD JENNY ENDS THAT ARE
RIDING ELEPHANTS. AND YOU DON'T
KNOW WHAT THE ELEPHANTS GONNA
DO. NO NEED TO REPLY THIS IS
RHETORICAL OKAY THANK GOD SO. I
BELIEVE THAT YOU ARE RIDING THE
ELEPHANT OF EVOLUTION WE
STARTED OUT JUST SIMPLY TRYING
TO TAKE CARE OF CIVIL WAR
VETERANS. YOU HIT THAT SPOT ON.
SO NOW WE HAVE EIGHT VETERANS
HOMES IN CALIFORNIA OF WITH
SUMMER BEING USED SUMMER NOT.
WE HAVE FROM WHAT I UNDERSTAND
I MAY BE WRONG EXACTLY BUT LIKE
A THIRD OF THE- HEADS ARE. WITH
HOMELESS VETERANS ECCENTRIC. SO
I WOULD LIKE TO SEE. FROM A
VETERAN VIEWPOINT THAT WOULD
TAKE CARE OF THE BRAIN INJURIES
THE ALZHEIMER'S AND THE PEOPLE
THAT NEED TO BE THERE. THE
HOMELESS WE GRANDFATHER
GRANDMOTHER IN TRYING TO BE
POLITICALLY CORRECT HERE. IN
AND SWITCHED TO THE ONES THAT
ARE- SEVERELY INJURED.
AFGHANISTAN AND I ROCKY
VETERANS HAVE A 20% HIGHER
CHANCE OF DEVELOPING
ALZHEIMER'S THAN US VIETNAM
VETERANS WHOA THAT'S RIGHT. SO.
AS A VETERAN I HAVE TO QUESTION
BECAUSE I'M AN ANALYTICAL NERD
I MEAN HOW MANY PEOPLE HAVE A
RULER IN THEIR POCKET. SHOULD
WE BE IN THE BUSINESS OF
VETERANS HOMES AND THINGS NO
THAT'S GUTSY TO SAY BECAUSE I
WOULD ALIENATE EVERY VETERAN
THEN I KNOW. SO WE HAVE TO AND
YOU'VE DONE A WONDERFUL
ANALYSIS OF THIS. SO EVERYTHING
IS EVOLUTIONARY IN CALIFORNIA
SHOULD WE- DO IT EVOLUTION TO
NOT PROVIDE BEDS TO THE
HOMELESS. AND GO TO WHAT BEDS
WE HAVE. FOR THE BRAIN INJURED
AND THE DISABLED. OKAY. AND YOU
YOU HAVE PUT THE ELEPHANT IN
THE ROOM. PARDON ME I'M REALLY
IN THE ELEPHANTS YOU KNOW. THAT
IS. THAT IS A HIDDEN JOKE MADAM.
MR SENATOR. SO BUT THE POINT
I'M MAKING IS. FROM MY NUMBERS
AND WHAT I UNDERSTAND AND
ANYONE CAN GOOGLE BEING
CALIFORNIA PROVIDES MORE
VETERANS BENEFITS IN OUR HOMES
I THINK IT'S AROUND THREE
HUNDRED EIGHTY MILLION IS THAT
CORRECT MISTER SECRETARY. AND I
ALSO UNDERSTAND THAT'S MORE
THAN FORTY SEVEN OTHER STATES
COMBINED. SO MUCH THERE'S NO
QUESTION THE CALIFORNIA
SUPPORTS VETERANS BUT IT'S HOW
WE SUPPORT THEM IN THIS REPORT.
IS SPOT ON. 87% MY OPINION IT'S
GREAT SO WHAT'S INTERESTING TO
ME IS WE HAVE ONE POINT SEVEN A
ONE POINT EIGHT MILLION
VETERANS WE HAVE A LIMITED
AMOUNT OF BEDS IN THE VETERANS
HOMES FOR WHATEVER REASON. AND
BASICALLY WERE RUNNING A
LOTTERY FOR VETERANS MAN IF YOU
HIT THE LOTTERY YOU GET IN A
WHAT A DEAL. SOME. ANOTHER
THING THIS. COMMITTEE NEEDS TO
CONSIDER IS HOW DO WE- REQUIRE
WAR. ADMIT VETERANS TO OUR
VETERANS HOMES NOW I STRONGLY
RECOMMEND ONCE AGAIN AND I'M IN
DEEP TROUBLE HERE I'M IN DEEP
DEEP TROUBLE FROM THE VETERANS
OF FOREIGN WARS AND MY BROTHERS
AND SISTERS IN. OTHER VETERANS
COMMUNITIES. ISN'T IT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT'S
RESPONSIBILITY FOR VETERANS
BECAUSE WHEN I WENT TO VIETNAM.
GUESS WHO SENT ME WAS IN
CALIFORNIA. JUST THE QUESTION
ASSEMBLY MEMBER I AB IF I IF I
MAY YES SIR YEAH YOU YOU YOU
NEVER REALLY ASKED ME A
QUESTION BUT YOU CREATED THIS
THE SENSE OF FOUR FIVE
QUESTIONS IF I COULD ROLL THEM
ALL UP INTO A OF A STATEMENT
FIRST SO I'M GONNA SALUTE YOU
AS A BROWN WATER IS I
UNDERSTAND YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE
IN VIETNAM AS A BROWN WATER
NAVY PERSONNEL- AYE AYE SHORT
TIME BROWN WATER A LONG TIME.
BLUE WATER BUT I GOT SHOT AT IN
BOTH AREAS I'M VERY HAPPY THAT
THE EXTENDED. IT'S BROWN WATER.
WELL WHAT YOU. FIRST OF ALL WE
WILL NEVER BE ABLE TO TAKE CARE
OF ALL OF OUR VETERANS BUT WE
MUST IF WE ARE TO HONOR ABRAHAM
LINCOLN'S PLEDGE THAT- TO CUT
TO THE LAST SENTENCE THAT WE
WILL- TAKE CARE OF THOSE WHO
HAVE BORNE THE BATTLE AND FOR
THEIR WIDOWS AND THE ORPHANS.
AND SO I DON'T THINK. GIVEN
THAT THE STATES ARE OVERFLOWED
THE STATE HOMES ARE AN OVERFLOW
FROM THE VA SYSTEM. IT'S LIKE
THE SEVENTH LEVEL OF CARE IF
YOU WILL. THE CEMETERIES OF THE
STATE RUNS ARE OVER FLOWS FROM
THE FEDERALS THE CEMETERIES
THERE IN PLACES WITH THE FEDS
ARE NOT ABLE TO GO WE TAKE UP
THAT BURDEN. THE STATES HAVE
ALWAYS DONE THAT SINCE ABRAHAM
LINCOLN- MANDATED THE STATE'S
TO THAT- CALIFORNIA CERTAINLY
WILL NEVER BE THE FIRST STATE
TO GO BACK ON THAT PROMISE. AND
BECAUSE PEOPLE DO ASK THE
QUESTION WHY ARE WE IN THE
BUSINESS WE'RE IN THE BUSINESS
OF RUNNING THE VETERANS HOMES
BECAUSE NOBODY ELSE CAN DO IT.
AND IT'S A JOB THAT NEEDS TO BE
DONE WILL ALWAYS NEED TO BE
DONE AS LONG AS WE HAVE
VETERANS. WILK WITH YOUR
GUIDANCE. A TO DO. THAT TO
QUESTION EVERYTHING I'VE SAID
ALWAYS AND TO ALWAYS LOOK TO DO
BETTER WITH WHAT YOU GIVE US TO
DO. I AM NOTE. THAT THE NUMBERS
THAT ARE COMING OUT US WILL BE.
ASTOUNDING WILL NEVER BE ABLE
TO AFFORD THAT. BUT WE DON'T
NEED TO TREAT EVERY VETERAN IN
OUR VETERANS HOME. THERE ONE
POINT SIX MILLION VETERANS IN
CALIFORNIA I CAN TELL YOU. THAT
ONE POINT SIX MILLION PEOPLE
ARE CALLING ME UP LOOKING FOR
BAD. MANY PEOPLE WHO NEED A
BETTER WHO ARE VETERANS ARE
STAYING WITH A FAMILY WITH
THEIR SPOUSE WITH THEIR
CHILDREN TO OUR COMMUNITIES
WITH A THE TENDONS AND IN HOME
HEALTHCARE AND ALL THE PROGRAMS
THE VA SUPPORT AND THE
COMMUNITY SUPPORT. THE
STRUCTURE IS THERE CALVET ITS
JOB IS TO MAKE EVERYBODY HOLD
HANDS TOGETHER. TO CREATE A WEB
OR BETTER YET A HAMMOCK BUT NO
ONE FALLS THROUGH. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU- VERY ONE LAST OKAY
BECAUSE WE DO NEED TO MOVE ON
TO THE SECOND PANEL. YES
PLEASE. SO THE OTHER THING HERE
AND WOMEN YOU CAN READ THROUGH.
HAVE ABOUT 22% HIGHER. SUICIDE
RATE THE MALE VETERANS SO
PERHAPS THIS COMMITTEE SHOULD
LOOK INTO THAT AS WELL AND I'M
DONE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER VOEPEL I'M
WORRIED NOW I'M GOING TO FINISH
WITH- SENATOR BROCK. THE SUN
ULTRA BE QUICK UP IN LET ME ASK
A COUPLE QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
MONEY AND THEN A QUESTION ABOUT
THE DOMICILIARY REST RESIDENTS
IN TERMS OF THE MONEY BEING A
BUDGET GUY HOW DOES THE HOW
DOES THE MONEY FLOW WITH
RESPECT TO THE SKILLED NURSING
FACILITY IS THAT A HUNDRED
PERCENT- REIMBURSED BY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT OR SOMETHING
LESS. SEVEN SEVEN HUNDRED-
PRESCRIPTION. I DON'T HAVE TO
THE DOLLAR BUT WHAT I CAN TELL
YOU IS THAT- IF YOU'RE ASKING
ABOUT WHAT WE WHAT WE GET
REIMBURSED VERSES WITH THE
STATE'S INVESTMENTS AND THAT
PROCESS OKAY WELL AS YOU KNOW
THE- GIVEN YOUR POSITION- WITH
YOU KNOW WITH REGARD TO THE
BUDGET- THE PROCESS IS THAT WE
GET OUR FUNDING UP FOR I GUESS
FOR ANYONE WHO ISN'T A WHERE WE
GET OUR FUNDING UP FRONT- AND
THEN THROUGHOUT THE YEAR WE
COLLECT A VARIETY OF A REVENUES
SOURCES AND WE- GIVE THAT BACK
TO THE STATE TO OFFSET AS MUCH
AS WE CAN AND IT'S A WIDE RANGE
OF- OF REVENUE STREAMS I COULD.
GO INTO IF ANYONE WOULD LIKE
BUT I WON'T FOR NOW IN THE
INTEREST OF TIME BUT- AS FOR
ONE OF THEM IS TO BE A PER DIEM
HELLO I THANK I HOPE I'M ANSWER
QUESTION ONE IS THAT RIGHT NOT
JUST TRYING TO DECIDE WHAT THE
UN REIMBURSED PORTION ON ON THE
STATE GENERAL FUND IS WITH
RESPECT TO THE SNIFF. BED WELL
I THINK IS. ON WHO. IN IT IF WE
HAVE- VETERAN IN IN SKILLED
NURSING WHO IS IT HAS A SERVICE
CONNECTED DISABILITY RATING OF
70% OR GREATER WE GET A MUCH
HIGHER PER DIEM. FROM THE VA
THAN A SKILLED NURSING THAT
WITH THE SERVICE CONNECTED.
SAID SERVICE CONNECTED
DISABILITY RATING OF LOWER THAN
THAT- LOWER IT SOMEWHERE IN THE
NEIGHBORHOOD OF A HUNDRED
DOLLARS A DAY GIVE OR TAKE- THE
70% AND GREATER IT'S SOMEWHERE
IN THE NEIGHBORHOOD OF FIVE
DOLLARS A DAY DEPENDS ON WHERE.
WOULD WHERE IN THE STATE THEY
LIVE- SO THE- UNREIMBURSED
COSTS. WOULD DEPEND ON WHETHER
THE- VA IS GIVING US THAT
HIGHER PER DIEM. FOR THAT
PERSON OR NOT. PART OF THE
ARRANGEMENT WITH THE VA IS THAT
IF THEY GIVE US THE HIGH IF
WE'RE GETTING THE HIGHER PER
DIEM. FOR A RESIDENT. THAT THE
VA IS INTENT AND IS THAT THAT.
COVERS ALL OF THEIR CARE SO WE
DON'T CHARGE THEM MEMBER FEET.
DON'T COLLECTED. THE OTHER
REVENUE SOURCES FOR THAT PERSON
BECAUSE- THAT IS INTENDED TO BE
THE- THE ENTIRE COST OF THEIR
CARE WHICH- IT IS- IT DOES
COVER OUR COSTS. OFTEN THE FOR
THE OTHER RESIDENTS THERE IS. A
DELTA THERE. AND OF COURSE IT
DEPENDS- ALMOST PERSON A PERSON
BECAUSE- PEOPLE'S MEMBER FEES
ARE AS YOU KNOW ARE BASED ON
THEIR INCOME AS OPPOSED TO-
WELL. IN STATUS BASED ON THEIR
INCOME THEIR CARE COST GROWTH
ARE BASED ON A RATE IN AND WHAT
THEY'RE GETTING IN THE WAY OF
CARE. BUT THERE MEMBER THE
BASED ON. ON THEIR INCOME SO.
AND OF COURSE THE
REIMBURSEMENTS ARE BASED ON
WHAT. THAT CARE THEY'RE BEING
PROVIDED SO THERE IS. A DELTA
BUT IT'S NOT IN. A SET. THAT I
COULD STATE FOR YOU BECAUSE IT
DEPENDS SYSTEM VETERANS PAY TO.
BE IN THE SNOW IF. YES AND THEN
WITH RESPECT TO THE- INTERIM.
K. OR THE. ASSISTED LIVING
MISSION. SO REMEMBER THE FABRIC.
OR IS THAT MEMBER PAID. BOTH WE
GET ALL OF THOSE REVENUE SOURCE
FOR ANYONE WHO IS NOT IN SKILL
NURSING AND SAID. PER OR HIGHER
THEIR SERVICE CONNECT
DISABILITY RATING. I TRIED FOR
ALL OF CARE WE WERE. FEE A PER
DIEM. IT'S SHE'S IT'S THE F.
DEPENDING ON THE SCENARIO ON
THE LEVEL OF CARE TO DIFFERENT
AMOUNTS. EVERYONE GETS AT LEAST
SOME PER DIEM. NOW WITH RESPECT
TO VETERANS WHO WERE IN THE IN
THE ROOMS THE DOMICILIARY
COMPONENT OF YOUR HOME
OPERATION. I THINK I HEARD YOU
CORRECTLY WE GET ABOUT FORTY
DOLLARS FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT PER INDIVIDUAL.
WHO'S IN A ROOM. TO THE TO THE
VETERANS PAY TO. LIVE IN THE
FACILITY. THE RATES ARE SET BY
THE MILITARY VETERANS CODE A
CERTAIN PROPORTION OF THEIR-
INCOME. NOT THEIR ASSETS OR
THEIR WEALTH. THEIR INCOME OKAY
AND I'VE HEARD SOME
CONVERSATION ABOUT HOMELESS DO
WE KNOW WHAT OUR DEMOGRAPHIC IS
ARE THESE REALLY HOMELESS
PEOPLE OR THESE PEOPLE WHO
CHOOSE TO LIVE IN OUR VETERANS
FACILITY BECAUSE THEY WANT TO
BE AROUND OTHER VETERANS. OR
FOR SOME OTHER NINE. HOUSING
NEED RELATED CORRECT ME IF I'M
WRONG 25% OF ALL THE ADMISSIONS
THE LAST TWO YEARS OF THE HOMES
ARE HOMELESS. THEY DO NOT HAVE.
AN ABILITY SOME OF THEM TO PAY
THE COST OF THEIR CARE. OKAY
AND THEN GIVEN THE CONVERSATION
THAT WE'VE HAD IN THIS ORDER
CENTER I'M SORRY ALSO THE FIRES
THAT BURNED UP NORTH BURNED A
LOT OF OUR MORTGAGE SHE'S OUT
AND SOME OF THEM. WE MADE WHOLE
AGAIN OTHERS WE TOOK INTO THE
HOME RIGHT. AND I'VE CERTAINLY
QUESTION IN THE PAST DURING MY
ALMOST EIGHT YEARS HERE ABOUT
WHY WE. PROVIDE A ROOMING
SERVICE FOR VETERANS I
UNDERSTAND IN THE DESERT DESIRE
FOR VETERANS TO BE AROUND OTHER
VETERANS AND I THINK THAT'S A
VALUABLE REASON TO DO
CONTINUING TO DO WHAT WE DO WE
JUST NEED TO REALIZE WHAT IT IS
BUT GIVEN THE CONVERSATION THAT
WE'VE HAD UP HERE RECENTLY OVER
THE PAST YEAR OR MORE ABOUT
HOUSING IN THE ADEQUACY OF THE
HOUSING SUPPLY AND IN SOME
CASES THE- LACK OF ADEQUATE
HOUSING. ACROSS THE BOARD.
ELIMINATING DHAMMA CELERY BEDS.
CAUSES ME SOME CONCERN. HOW HOW
MUCH OF A VOUCHER WOULD WE NEED
TO PROVIDE AS A STATE TO
VETERANS IF WE CHOSE TO GO IN
TERMS OF DOLLARS AND WOOD GIVEN
WHAT IT COST TO HOUSE THE
VETERAN IN REVISED BAKER NO
ONE'S GOING TO BE ASKED TO
LEAVE AND BE GIVEN A VOUCHER
TOLD TO LEAVE THAT THE PEOPLE
OF HER DOMICILIARY SHOULD THEY
EVEN LIVE FORTY MORE YEARS
THEY'LL CONTINUE TO STAY AT THE
HOME SO JUST PROGRESS TO HIGHER
LEVELS OF KERR BUT WE'RE
ELIMINATING BEDS. I WON'T
ELIMINATING BEDS BUT IF YOU'LL
SEE WITH THIS YEAR'S B. C. P.
AND IDEALLY IN FUTURES I'M I'M
HOPING TO LOG ON A DIFFERENT
LEVEL OF CARE WELL I'M JUST
TRYING TO GET TO THE NUMBER DID
YOU ALL DO THE ANALYSIS WHAT
SORT OF VOUCHERS IS WOULD WE
HAVE TO IMPLEMENT. IT HOW MUCH
WOULD IT COST TO PROVIDE
HOUSING FOR VETERANS SHOULD WE
CHOOSE TO DO SO WHO OTHER WHAT
LIVE IN OUR THE SILVERY BED ONE
AND TWO. IS AN ADEQUATE HOUSING
SUPPLY GIVEN THE AMOUNT OF
MONEY THAT WE SPEND ON THE
MYSTERY BEDS PER OCCUPANT. TO
ALLOW CUBANS TO. SIX HOUSING IN
THE IN THE SO COMMUNITY WELL
MAKES IS THAT A FOR NINE SO AND
WE DIDN'T A SPECIFIC OF IN WHAT
WOULD TAKE I GUESS TO. AT TO
PROVIDE YOU KNOW TO OFFER THEM
HOUSING ELSEWHERE- WE DID
REVIEW OTHER PROGRAMS US OFFICE
AND AS YOU KNOW THE VA OPERATES
THE VAST PROGRAM. RUN NUMBER
OTHER SERVICES LIKE THAT- SO WE
EVALUATED THOUGH SO I GUESS I
GUESS THE BEST ENSURING THAT
WOULD BE WE WOULD HAVE TO
DETERMINE. THE AMOUNT OF MONEY
THAT THOSE PROGRAMS ARE
PROVIDING WITH THEIR WITH THEIR
SHORTCOMINGS ARE. AND WHAT
MIGHT RELATE TO THE DOES A
POPULATION BUT AGAIN EVEN IF
SAID THAT THE REALITIES AS WE
COULD WE COULD. WE COULD NOT
ELIMINATED SINGLE DUMP WE COULD
WE GET THE DONS AS THEY ARE
RIGHT NOW. M. AT THE BUDGET
LEVELS INTO PERPETUITY- BUT THE
REALITY IS WE HAVE. WE WILL
INVADE A HUNDRED FIFTEEN BED
THE COUPLE YEARS AGO FOR YOU
OFFER TO GIVE EVERYONE PRIVATE
ROOMS- AND DESPITE LIMITED HOW
TO FIFTEEN WE HAVE SOMETHING
LIKE FIFTY OR SEVENTY. SIX
RIGHT. ARE STILL OTHER. THIRTY
THE- SO. THE E. IF WE DON'T
CHANGE THE NUMBER BUDGET BEDS
ARE LIMITED WE IF WE KEEP THEM
AS THEY ARE. THAT DOESN'T MEAN
THAT THE DOMICILIARY WON'T GO
AWAY ON ITS OWN. WELL AT. THE
POINT IN TIME WHERE YOU START
TO MAKE DECISIONS ON WHETHER TO
RELOCATE HOMES. AS YOU MOVE OUT
OF THE VA OBLIGATION PERIOD AND
YOU HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO DO
SO. YOU WILL HAVE TO ADDRESS
THIS QUESTION. BECAUSE YOU HAVE
DOUBLE CELERY BEDS TODAY IN THE
QUESTION IS DO YOU REPLICATE
THOSE BEDS WHEN YOU GO TO THE
NEW LOCATION. OR DO YOU SHIFT
TO A VOUCHER SYSTEM. SHOULD THE
LEGISLATURE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION DECIDED TO MOVE
IN THAT DIRECTION. TO AFFORD
VETERANS THE OPPORTUNITY. WITH
ASSISTANCE TO LIVE IN A-
PARTICULAR SIEVE BUT FACILITY
IN THE CIVILIAN COMMUNITY SO
WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO KNOW THAT.
WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO KNOW WHAT
YOUR COST IS. WHAT IT WOULD
COST TO PROVIDE A VOUCHER AND
WHAT THE AVAILABILITY OF. OF
ADEQUATE HOUSING IS IN A
PARTICULAR AREA AND LOS ANGELES
WOULD BE DEVASTATING. RIVERSIDE
SABATINO PERHAPS NOT SO MUCH
FRESNO MERCED MAY BE BETTER SO
IT JUST DEPENDS ON WHERE YOU
ARE AND WHAT FACILITY YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT A WHERE YOU'RE
GOING TO TAKE IT SO THAT'S THE
REASON FOR MY QUESTION. I WANT
TO BELABOR THIS WILL HAVE THIS
CONVERSATION I'M SURE AT SOME
FUTURE POINT THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR I APOLOGIZE- CERTAINLY
BUT NOW WE HAVE SENATOR UMBERG
WHO HAS A ONE QUICK QUESTION.
THAT I APOLOGIZE I HAVE THIS
STUFF OUT FOR A FEW MOMENTS- SO
YOU EARLIER BEFORE I LET YOU
SAID THERE THAT BAR SO AS FOUR
HUNDRED BEDS RIGHT. AND THE-
TOTAL TOTAL FOR FOUR AND HOW
MANY ARE OCCUPIED. SO THERE
THERE ARE FOUR HUNDRED TOTAL
POTENTIAL BEDS OF THE POTENTIAL
BUT RIGHT SO- AND THAT'S WHAT
IS CONSTRUCTED BOARDS
CONSTRUCTED BE A FOUR HUNDRED
BED FACILITY. I'M RIGHT NOW
THERE ARE ONLY TWO HUNDRED AND
TWENTY THAT ARE BUDGETED. SO
THERE'S A HUNDRED EIGHTY BEDS
THAT ARE AN BUDGETED- THAT
HYPOTHETICALLY THAT SO COULD
HAVE THAT IF WE GAVE IT WENT
OVER ROOM HAS THE CAPACITY IF
WE INCREASE RIGHT AND FAMILY
OCCUPIED RIGHT NOW AND SO I THE
TWENTY TWENTY THERE'S ABOUT. A
HUNDRED EIGHTY OR SO THAT ARE
OCCUPIED SO MOST VACANCIES IN
THE DOWN PROGRAM OKAY WELL ON
OFF LINE WE COULD ADDRESS SIR.
OTHER ISSUES CONCERNING BUS
STOP OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU LADIES GERMAN NOW
WILL GO ON TO THE SECOND. PART
OF OUR PANEL DISCUSSION AND-
MISTER SECRETARY LIKE TO THANK
YOU FOR APPEARING WITH YOUR-
WITH YOUR TEAM. AS YOU KNOW WE
CAN DO THIS- WITHOUT YOU.
BECAUSE YOU ARE THE LEADER.
THAT WE LOOK UP TO. AND WE KNOW
YOU DON'T DO THIS ALONE AND-
YOUR PARTNERSHIP. WITH ALL THE
OTHER- FACILITIES AGENCIES AND
SHOW ONE. OF AYE AYE YOUR TO DO
AN OUTSTANDING JOB ONCE AGAIN
CONGRATULATIONS. SO NOW MY
QUESTION IS DO WE HAVE THE
SECOND. GROUP ARE THEY HERE
THANK YOU AND THAT WOULD BE
JACK CLEAN- BUT CHERYL IN AT
ETHAN. RADIC AND CHUCK HELP GET.
OKAY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE SO WE'LL GO ON- WITH
THEIR SECOND HALF OF THE PANEL
DISCUSSION SHOW. SURE YOU HAVE
THE FLOOR. THANK YOU ALL OF MY
ART I HAVEN'T BROUGHT SEE A
LITTLE STATE ANALYST OFF WOULD
YOU IDENTIFY YOURSELF PLEASE
YEAH JACQUELINE BRAZIL
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
GREAT TO BE HERE. I'M MAINLY WE
WERE ASKED TO PROVIDE A
BACKGROUND TO WHAT LED UP TO
THE CREATION OF THE MASTER PLAN
AND REALLY HIGHLIGHTING THE
LEGISLATURE'S ROLE IN
CONTRIBUTING TO THE- TO THE
CREATION OF THE MASTER PLAN.
I'M SO TODAY MY COMMENTS WILL
MAINLY FOCUS ON EXPLAINING THE
VARIOUS LEGISLATIVE ACTIONS-
THAT. HAVE BEEN TAKEN TO ONE
ASSESS WHETHER THE CURRENT
ARRAY OF SERVICES PROVIDED IN
THE STATE. ARE ADEQUATE ENOUGH
TO MEET THE CHANGING NEEDS OF.
FRIENDS I'M IN THE FUTURE. AND
HOW THAT FIT INTO THAN THIS
CONCEPTION OF A MASTER PLAN AND
THEN I'LL END MY COMMENTS BY
JUST RAISING KEY QUESTIONS THAT
THE LEGISLATURE SHOULD CONSIDER
AS THEIR PROCESSING THE
FINDINGS IN THE RECOMMENDATIONS
THAT ARE LAID OUT IN THE MASTER
PLAN. I WILL NOTE I MEAN IT'S A
THREE HUNDRED PAGE DOCUMENT.
GEN TEND THERE'S ANOTHER THINK.
ALSO TAKING UP SOME OF MY
WORKLOAD SO I'M TRYING MY BEST
AND WE'RETRYING OUR BEST TO
ANALYZE THE SPECIFIC CONTENT OF
THE MASTER PLAN AND HOPEFULLY-
SOON WILL BE ABLE TO. PROVIDE
MORE ANALYTICAL COMMENTS ON THE
PEACE BUT FOR NOW PROVIDING
SOME HIGH LEVEL COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS TO HELP THE MEMBER
STATE A STE. WHAT WAS PRESENT
AT OKAY THANK YOU SO I'LL JUST
START OFF FIRST- BY STATING
THAT AS A PART OF THOSE SIXTEEN
SEVENTEEN BUDGET OUR OFFICE WE
WERE DIRECTED BY THE
LEGISLATURE TO EVALUATE THE
EXISTING LANDSCAPE OF VETERAN
SERVICES HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
AND IDENTIFY POSSIBLE WAYS IN
WHICH WE CAN IMPROVE SERVICE
DELIVERY TO VETERANS. I'M SOME
OF THE MAIN TAKEAWAYS FROM OUR
REPORT INCLUDE THAT ONE CAL
THAT IS JUST ONE OF MANY
SERVICE PROVIDERS TO VETERANS.
AND SOME SERVICE PROVIDERS-
OPERATE AT DIFFERENT LEVELS OF
GOVERNMENT THE FEDERAL LOCAL
LEVEL WHILE OTHERS ARE NON
PROFITS. ADDITIONALLY SOME
SERVICE PROVIDERS SPECIFICALLY
FOCUSED ON VETERANS LIKE THE VA
SYSTEM WHILE OTHERS VETERANS IS
JUST ONE. POPULATION THAT THEY
SERVE- WITHIN THE THEIR THEIR
BROADER- ELIGIBILITY POOL. TO
THEIR AND ARE NOW OF A LEAST OF
A HOME THERE PENT UP DEMAND AT
CERTAIN LEVELS OF I THINK YOU
YOU HEARD THAT THAT REALLY IS
IN THE SKILLED NURSING AND-
MEMORY CARE BEDS. THIRD CALVET
ADMIN ARE NOW SAYS A WHILE
THERE ARE BETTER SITUATED TO
MEET THE NEEDS OF CERTAIN
VETERANS THERE WAS- WE- IN OUR
CONVERSATIONS WITH CAL THAT
THERE IS A RECOGNITION THAT
THEY DID HAVE LIMITED CAPACITY
TO MEET THE NEEDS OF VETERANS
WITH COMPLEX HEALTH AND
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH NEEDS. AND
GIVEN THE CORRELATION BETWEEN
THAT AND IT VETERANS THAT HAVE
EXPERIENCE HOMELESSNESS A COULD
APPLIED TO ALSO THE HOMELESS
POPULATION AS WELL. AND LASTLY
IN OUR REPORT WE DID FIND THAT
CERTAIN VETERANS HOME DO HAVE-
HIRING CHALLENGES AND RETENTION
ISSUES- SO JUST HIGHLIGHTING
THAT AS A AS A CHALLENGE IN
OPERATING THE HOMES TODAY. SO
IN LIGHT OF THESE FINDINGS ARE
OFFICE IDENTIFIED KEY
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO IMPROVE SERVICE
DELIVERY AT THE VETERANS HOMES
SUCH AS ONE POSSIBLY LOOKING AT
THE- ELIGIBILITY CRITERIA AND
PRIORITIZING SIR AND- VETERANS
FOR ADMISSIONS OR DIRECTING THE
DEPARTMENT TO CONSIDER WAYS IN
WHICH IT COULD ALIGN ITS
CURRENT LEVELS OF CARE.
PROVIDED IN THE VETERANS HOMES
TO BETTER REFLECT THE HANGING
NEEDS OF THE VETERANS
POPULATION. ON ADDITIONALLY WE
NOTED HOW THE LEGISLATURE COULD
DIRECT- THE DEPARTMENT TO
DETERMINE WHAT ABOUT THE
OPERATIONS IN THE HOMES WOULD
HAVE TO CHANGE TO BETTER MEET
THE NEEDS OF VETERANS WITH
COMPLEX MENTAL AND BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH NEEDS. AND HOPEFULLY
THROUGH THAT TO BETTER SERVE
VETERANS THAT HAVE EXPERIENCE
HOMELESSNESS IN THE PAST. AND
LASTLY WE- ACKNOWLEDGING THAT
SOME HOMES DO FACE CHALLENGING
HIRING A RETENTION SHOES FOR
EMPLOYEES- THE LEGISLATURE
COULD HAVE ALSO CONSIDERED
DIRECTING CAL THAT WORK WITH
CALLIE CHART IN A FIVE ARE
THERE BURDENSOME AND
UNNECESSARY CRITERIA OR
PROCESSES IN PLACE WHEN IT
COMES TO THE STATE HIRING
PROCESS THAT COULD BE
ALLEVIATED. AND IN SOME WAYS
HELP SOME OF THESE HOMES- BUT
ALSO A COULD THE DEPARTMENT
REPORT BCK TO THE LEGISLATURE.
TO RETENTION CHALLENGE AT THE
WHOLE LEVEL SO IT COULD BE
SOMETHING THAT THE LEGISLATURE
TO CONSIDER WHEN LOOKING AT THE
WHEN I'M THINKING ABOUT SHINS
FOR THE ANNUAL BUDGET PROCESS.
FOR EXAMPLE SOMETHING THAT
COULD BE CONSIDERED IT IS
PROVIDING TARGETED HIRING EVERY
INCH AND FUNDS TO CERTAIN HOMES
FOR THE POSITIONS THAT ARE VERY
DIFFICULT TO FILL. I SO WITH
THAT. I AFTER THE POP. OF OUR
WORK. AS A TO THE SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN BY THE- MADE AN FROM.
BUT TRY TO GET AT CHANGING THE
VETERANS HOMES. ONE OF THEM WAS
CONVERTING TRANSITIONAL-
HOUSING PROGRAM BEDS TO SKILLED
NURSING IN THE GREATER LOS
ANGELES AND VENTURA COUNTY HOME
AND THEN ANOTHER WAS EXPANDING
THE PRIORITIZATION CRITERIA TO
VETERANS WITH THE 70% OR HIGHER
SERVICE CONNECTED DISABILITY.
AND BOTH PROPOSALS WERE PROVED
BUT I THINK THEY ALSO SERVES TO
CONTINUE THIS BROADER
CONVERSATION OF OLD WHAT WHAT'S
THE ULTIMATE VISION OF THE
VETERANS HOMES AND HOW ARE WE
MEETING THE CHANGING NEEDS OF
VETERANS IN THE FUTURE. SO AS A
RESULT AND THE LEGISLATURE
DIRECTED THE ADMINISTRATION TO
DEVELOP A SYSTEM WIDE MASTER
PLAN SEVEN AS A PART OF THE
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN BUDGET AND
INITIAL COMPONENTS OF THE
MASTER PLAN INCLUDED. FOLLOW UP
ANALYSIS ON HOW THE NEW
ADMISSION POLICIES WOULD AFFECT
OTHER VETERANS THE OPERATIONS
OF THE HOMES AND REVENUES AN
ASSESSMENT OF THE CURRENT AND
PROJECTED LONG TERM CARE NEEDS
OF VETERANS. HOW DO A LINE EACH
LEVEL OF CARE AT EACH HOME WITH
THE FUTURE NEEDS OF VETERANS
BUT ALSO INCLUDING HOW TO BEST
SERVE VETERANS WITH COMPLEX
MENTAL BEHAVIOR HEALTH NEEDS IT
WITH THE HOMES. OF AND
EVALUATION OF LEASES AT THE
HOMES AND CONSIDERTION OF THE
ADDITION OF FACILITIES AS OUT
PAID CLINIC OR MULTI FAMILY
HOUSING. IN IN EIGHTEEN
EIGHTEEN THE PLEDGES FOR. BY
EXPECTATIONS OF MASTER. BY MORE
COME. LIKE ASSESSING THE NEED
TO EXPAND OR MODIFY OR CLOTHES
OR EVEN OPEN MORE FACILITIES
BASED OFF OF THE FINDINGS OF
HOW THE CHANGING NEEDS OF
VETERANS WOULD LOOK LIKE.
CONSIDER WAYS OF PROVIDING
SERVICES THROUGH DIFFERENT
MODELS SUCH AS COMMUNITY BASED
CARE SERVICE DELIVERY MODELS
THAT WOULD ALLOW VETERANS TO
AGE IN PLACE. AND RECEIVE
SERVICES WITHIN THEIR EXISTING
HOMES OR COMMUNITIES. I'M ALSO
A SAYS THE LOCAL AREA COST OF
LIVING FOR EMPLOYEES AT CURRENT
AND ANY FUTURE PROPOSED SITES.
ADDITIONALLY THE LEGISLATURE
THEY CLARIFIED THEIR DESIRE TO
HAVE THE MASTER PLAN BE A
LIVING DOCUMENT AND WITH THAT-
REQUIRED THAT THE MASTER PLAN
SHALL BE UPDATED EVERY FIVE
YEARS UPON THE INITIAL RELEASE.
SO NOW THAT I SET UP THAT
BACKGROUND- ALL MOVE INTO A
KIND OF THE KEY QUESTIONS THAT-
WE- WE WOULD SUGGEST THE
LEGISLATURE KEEPS IN MIND AS
THEIR PROCESSING THE FINDINGS
AND RECOMMENDATIONS AGAIN WE'RE
STILL ANALYZING THE MASTER PLAN
SO WHILE OUR- COMMENTS CAN'T
CPAS CAN'T- ART SPECIFIC TO
THE- PROCESSES OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS HOPEFULLY WE
COULD GET. TO THAT AT A LATER
DATE- SO THE FIRST QUESTION
THAT WE WOULD RAISE IS WHAT
PREDICTIONS DOES THE MAP MASTER
PLAN MAKE AND HOW- IN HOW THE
NEEDS OF VETERANS WILL CHANGE
OVER TIME AND- AS WAS
MENTIONED- IT'S IT SOUNDS LIKE
THE- PROJECTIONS WERE CROSS
CUTTING AND THAT THEY BOTH
LOOKED AT. THE GENERAL
POPULATION OF VETERANS BUT THEN
ALSO THE NEEDS OF SUB GROUPS
THOSE WITH COMPLEX BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH NEEDS THOSE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS. AND ON PIECE WERE
STILL PROCESSING IN TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND TO THE DATA THAT WAS
USED TO CONSTRUCT THESE
PRODUCTIONS AND TO ASSESS THEIR
PORTABILITY TO CALIFORNIA.
ANOTHER QUESTION THAT THE
LEGISLATURE MAY WANT TO KEEP IN
MIND AS- FOR EACH OF THESE
RECOMMENDATIONS AND FINDINGS
DOES THE MASTER PLAN LAID OUT A
CLEAR PATH FORWARD ON WHAT
ABOUT THE VETERANS HOME
SPECIFICALLY WOULD HAVE TO
CHANGE TO BETTER MEET THE NEEDS
OF VETERANS IN THE FUTURE- AND
IF NOT IS THAT SOMETHING THAT
COULD BE FURTHER EXPLORED OR
TEASE DOUBT AND FUTURE
ITERATIONS. OF THE MASTER PLAN.
ANOTHER QUESTION IS WITH ALL OF
THESE RECOMMENDATIONS WHAT ARE
THE TOP PRIORITIES AMONGST THE
ADMINS AMONGST THE
ADMINISTRATION- WHAT'S THE
TIMELINE OF ROLLING OUT THE
RECOMMENDATIONS WHAT'S THE
NECESSARY RESOURCES- TO DO SO.
I HOW WILL THE ADMINISTRATION
USED THE RECOMMENDATIONS AND
FINDINGS IN THE MASTER PLAN TO
DIE TO THEIR FUTURE BUDGET AND
POLICY WORK. AND WHAT'S THE
ROLE FOR THE LEGISLATURE IN
THAT PROCESS HOW WILL THE
LEGISLATURE BEING GAUGED AND
MAKING THOSE DECISIONS. ON MORE
THE LEGISLATURE HOW CAN THE
LEGISLATURE USE THE MASTER PLAN
TO ALSO ELEVATE THEIR
PRIORITIES AND WHAT THEY WANT
TO SEE OUT OF THE VETERANS HOME
SYSTEM BUT MORE BROADLY MAY BE
OUT OF THE SERVICES PROVIDED
THROUGH CAL BUT IN GENERAL- AND
AGAIN THIS COULD BE SOMETHING
THAT THE LEGISLATURE COULD-
ADDED INTO FUTURE ITERATIONS OF
THE MASTER PLAN I THINK. A LOT
OF MEMBERS HERE EXPRESS THEIR
DESIRE TO FURTHER EXPLORE
ADMISSIONS POLICY TO FURTHER
EXPLORE- IF FOR NOT PROVIDING
LIKE SENATOR OUT THE FOR NOT
PROVIDING DOMICILIARY CARE
WHAT. CAN WE PROVIDE THAT STILL
GETS AT THAT HOUSING THE BUT
IT'S A DIFFERENT SERVICE MODEL.
I'M I'M ASSEMBLY MEMBER YOU
MENTION AND WHAT ABOUT THE H.
H. P. EXPANSION- ACKNOWLEDGING
THAT THE PLAN IS SPECIFIC TO
VETERANS OWNS BUT IS THAT
SOMETHING THAT COULD BE
EXPLORED AND FUTURE ITERATIONS
AND IF SO HOW CAN THE
LEGISLATURE- COMMUNICATE THAT
THAT'S THAT'S WHAT THEY WOULD
LIKE TO SEE. AN OF SPRING MARKS.
AND LASTLY I WOULD KNOW THAT-
THERE'S THIS BROADER QUESTION
OF HOW DOES THE MASTER PLAN
PRESENTED BY CAL THAT FIT INTO
OTHER STATEWIDE INITIATIVES
THAT THE- THE LEGISLATURE AND
THE ADMINISTRATION IS CURRENTLY
TAKING ON. FOR EXAMPLE- THE
ADMINISTRATION IS ENGAGING IN
CONSTRUCTING A MASTER PLAN FOR
AGING AND THIS IS A BROAD LOOK
ON. HOW HOW ARE WE REALIGNING
STATE PROGRAMS- LOCAL PROGRAMS
IN GENERAL TO MEET THE LONG
TERM SERVICES PORTS NEEDS OF
SENIORS MOVING FORWARD- THERE'S
SOME CLEAR OVERLAP THERE WITH
THE MASTER PLAN CALVET SO
THERE'S JUST A QUESTION OF HOW
THEY WILL. INTERACT WITH ONE
ANOTHER. AND ANOTHER STATEWIDE
INITIATIVE THAT WAS MENTIONED
IS. THE AUDIT OF STATE LAND AND
THE POTENTIAL UED TO INCREASE
THE SUPPLY OF HOUSING SO HOW
DOES THAT ALSO INTERPLAY WITH
THE FINDINGS LAID OUT IN THE
MASTER PLAN AND THEIR
ASSESSMENT OF FUTURE FACILITY
USES. SO BAD DAHLE PASS IT ON
TO THE OTHER PANELISTS. THANK
YOU OKAY I. YOURSELF THANK YOU
CERTAINLY. THANK YOU AND MISTER
CHAIR MADAM MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE HI MY NAME IS ETHAN
RARICK I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE LITTLE HOOVER
COMMISSION. I WHICH IS AN
INDEPENDENT STATE OVERSIGHT
AGENCY THAT INCLUDES FOR
MEMBERS OF THE LEGISLATURE
INCLUDING SENATOR ROTH THANK
YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE ON THE
COMMISSION CENTER. I AND NINE
PUBLIC MEMBERS WERE APPOINTED
BY THE GOVERNOR AND LEGISLATIVE
LEADERSHIP WE ARE CHARGED IN
STATUE WITH MAKING%
RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR.
ABOUT WAYS TO IMPROVE THE
EFFICIENCY OF STATE GOVERNMENT
I WANTED TO PROVIDE A BIT A
BRIEF BACKGROUND ABOUT THE-
WORK OF THE LITTLE HOOVER
COMMISSION ON THE VETERANS
HOMES- ISSUE. AND HOW I THINK
THAT- THAT LED TO THE MASTER
PLAN AND HOW THE MASTER PLAN
RESPONSE TO SOME OF OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS. I IN TWO
THOUSAND AND FIFTEEN- CHAIR-
WHEN ASKED THE- COMMISSION TO
STUDY THE FUTURE OF-
CALIFORNIA'S VETERANS HOMES
AFTER A LENGTHY STUDY THE
COMMISSION ISSUED TWO REPORTS.
IN TWO THOUSAND AND SEVENTEEN
THE FIRST OF THOSE REPORTS-
PROVIDED RECOMMENDATIONS TO
UPDATE AND MODERNIZE THE HOMES-
GENERALLY THE HOMES PROGRAM
GENERALLY AND THE SECOND
FOCUSED ON THE STATE'S LARGEST
AND OLDEST HOME IN YON PHIL-
THE COMPLETION OF THE MASTER
PLAN- FOR FILLS- ONE OF THE
COMMISSION'S PRIMARY
RECOMMENDATIONS WHICH WAS TO
ASSESS- EACH OF THE VETERANS
HOMES AND THE NEEDS OF THE
VETERANS POPULATION IN.
CALIFORNIA TAKING INTO ACCOUNT
THINGS LIKE CHANGING
DEMOGRAPHICS AND LONG TERM
PROJECTED LONG TERM CARE NEEDS.
ADDITIONALLY OUT WE BELIEVE
THAT THE MASTER PLAN- SOMETIMES
IN CONJUNCTION WITH. SOME OF
THE LEGISLATION THE JACQUI
ALREADY MENTIONED- THAT THE
MASTER PLAN ADDRESS THE NUMBER.
COMMITTEE FROM THE MISSION I
INCLUDING THE PRIVATIZATION OF
EMISSIONS. THOSE VETERANS THE
GREAT NEED. INCREASE FOCUS ON
NURSING AND SKILLED NURSING
MEMORY CARE. THE GRADUAL
ELIMINATION OF DOMICILIARY CARE
AT THE WITH- ANY. ROOTED IN THE
MASTER PLAN. I OUTSIDE OF THOSE
GENERAL RECOMMENDATIONS. OF THE
COMMISSION URGED CALVET TO
THINK CREATIVELY ABOUT THE
FUTURE OF THE YOUNG BILL.
CAMPUS WHICH AS YOU ALL KNOW IS
A VERY LARGE CAMPUS
GEOGRAPHICALLY NOT ONLY TERMS A
NUMBER OF BEDS BUT AS A LOT OF
ACRES. AGAIN WE ARE PLEASED TO
SEE THAT A NUMBER OF THESE
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THE
COMMISSION. ARE EMBODIED IN THE
MASTER PLAN FIRST AND FOREMOST
THE COMMISSION CALLED FOR
CONSTRUCTION OF THE NEW SKILLED
NURSING FACILITY AT YOUNTVILLE
THAT IS- IN PROCESS NOW. AND
PRIORITIZED IN THE MASTER PLAN.
THE COMMISSION ALSO CALLED FOR
LONG TERM PLANNING FOR THE
YACHT BILL CAMPUS IN A WAY THAT
MEETS THE NEEDS OF RESIDENTS.
WHILE ALSO LOOKING FOR OTHER
USES THAT COULD BENEFIT BOTH
THE LOCAL COMMUNITY AND
VETERANS STATEWIDE. AGAIN THIS
RECOMMENDATION IS EMBODIED IN
THE MASTER PLANS CALL FOR THIRD
PARTY DEVELOPMENT THAT WOULD
BENEFIT BOTH BOTH THE RESIDENTS
AND THE COMMUNITY. ARE THERE
ARE OTHER COMMISSION
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WOULD
REQUIRE ADDITIONAL ACTION FROM
THE LEGISLATURE. OF FOR EXAMPLE
THE COMMISSION RECOMMENDED
ALTERING THE FEE STRUCTURE SO
THAT IT WOULD BE BASED. ON COST
OF CARE NOT ON PERCENTAGE OF
INCOME IN ANSWER TO YOUR
EARLIER QUESTION CENTER. UNDER
THE CURRENT MILITARY AND
VETERANS CODE- VETERANS ARE
CHARGED A PERCENTAGE OF THEIR
INCOME. TO LIVE IN THE HOME OF
THE COMMISSION RECOMMENDED
CHANGING TO SOME FORMULA- THAT
WOULD BE BASED ON COST OF CARE
BUT THAT WOULD REQUIRE.
PROVISION OF THE MILITARY AND
VETERANS COAT. IN SHORT WE
BELIEVE MANY OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS IN THE MASTER
PLANNER IN ACCORD WITH THE-
COMMISSION'S RECOMMENDATIONS
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH- CALVET IN THE LEGISLATURE
IN THE ADMINISTRATION AND-
FURTHER- IMPLEMENTATION. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU WOULD YOU PLEASE
STATE YOUR NAME. JEFF NO NO
CHUCK HELD AT- I REPRESENT OR
IN THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION VETERANS SERVICE
AGENCIES CULTURE ARCH LETTER.
AND WHEN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- I'M HERE TODAY TO
TALK- ON BEHALF OF THE BOARD OF
MY BOARD OF DIRECTORS AND
GRATEFUL THAT FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO DELIVER THIS
BRIEF OVERVIEW OVER TWENTY
NINETEEN STATE OF THE VETERAN
COMMUNITY REPORT. CABS IT WAS
ORGANIZED IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
FIVE IS A CONSORTIUM NOW SEVEN
COMMUNITY BASED VETERAN
SPECIFIC NONPROFIT AGENCIES.
OPERATING FROM Y. RICA EUREKA
TO US SAN DIEGO- WE PROVIDE
HOUSING IN SUPPORT OF SERVICES
FOR VETERANS. AND THEIR
FAMILIES AND IN MANY WAYS WE
SUPPLEMENT THE MASTER PLAN THAT
YOU'VE DISCUSSED TODAY IN THE
HOMES PROGRAM AS NON PROFITS WE
PROVIDE THAT SECOND BASE OF
SUPPORT FOR THE VETERANS IN
PROVIDING THEM WITH HOUSING
AND- SUPPORT SERVICES. US IS
TWENTY SEVENTEEN CABS HAS BEEN
PREPARING AN ANNUAL REPORT I'M
ON THE STATE OF THAT OUR
COMMUNITY IN CALIFORNIA WITH A
FOCUS ON MENTAL HEALTH RELATED
ISSUES. THE REPORT WAS BECAUSE-
PREPARED FOR CABS TO BY DOCTOR
KATHLEEN WEST AND THROUGH THE
SUPPORT OF THE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION- OVER
THE PLUS PASSED OVER YEARS THIS
REPORT IS HELPED INFORM US ON
OUR POLICY LEGISLATIVE
PRIORITIES. WE RECENTLY EXCUSE
ME COMPLETED THE TWENTY
NINETEEN ANNUAL REPORT I'D LIKE
TO BRIEFLY SHARE WITH YOU SOME
OF OUR KEY FINDINGS MANY OF
WHICH OVERLAP WITH THE MASTER
PLAN DISCUSSION EARLIER TODAY.
IT IS JUST AS BEEN DISCUSSED AT
LENGTH TODAY MORE BUTTON MORE
VETERANS LIVE IN CALIFORNIA
THAN ANY OTHER STATE ABOUT 8%
OF ALL VETERANS LIVE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA- ONE POINT SIX
MILLION VETERANS- SUPPLEMENTED
BY FIFTY SEVEN THOUSAND- MORE
MEMBERS OF THE SELECTED
RESERVE- NEARLY HALF OF
CALIFORNIA'S ONE POINT SIX
MILLION VETERANS ARE SENIOR
CITIZENS. EVEN WITH THIS BRIDGE
POPULATION OF VETERANS
CALIFORNIA HAS NEARLY A HUNDRED
FOUR THOUSAND FEAR VETERANS
TODAY THAT WE HAD IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN. MISTER KLEIN IS
PROJECTED TO CONTINUE THE
NEARLY HALF OF. THAT IN THE
NIGHT SIXTY FIVE THERE'S NO. DE.
HELLO HE HAS CLEAR BLUE.
DISCUSSED EARLIER TODAY THERE'S
NEED FOR ELDER CARES. OF THAT
ARE NOT AS- IN PLACING CAL.
VECTOR CARE POOR. TODAY THE
AGING VETERAN POPULATION
PARTICULARLY THE CHRONICALLY
HOMELESS POPULATION- SUFFERS
FROM MANY CHRONIC AND SEVERE
HEALTH AND MENTAL HEALTH
CONCERNS AND CHRONICALLY
HOMELESS VETERANS ARE AGING
WELL BEYOND THEIR YEARS. THIS
DINING FACT THESE DAUNTING
FACTS WILL REQUIRE INCREASINGLY
EXPENSIVE CARE FOR SERVICES
SUCH AS SKILLED NURSING CARE
HOSPICE CARE LIVE IN AIDS
SPECIFICALLY DESIGNED HOUSING
AND MEDICATION MANAGEMENT.
THESE ISSUES ARE SHARED NOT THE
IMPACT OF THESE ISSUES ARE
SHARED BY CAVS FACILITIES AS
WELL AS YOUR VETERAN HOME
PROGRAM. NOW HEALTH CHALLENGES
AFFECT VETERANS OF ALL AGES IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN WHITE MALES
OVER THE AGE OF SIXTY FIVE OR
THE HIGHEST AT THE HIGHEST RISK
OF SUICIDE DEATH BY SUICIDE-
CONSTITUTING 54% OF ALL
CALIFORNIA VETERANS WHO SIDES.
64% OF WHOM USED FIREARM TO
TAKE THEIR LIFE COMPARED 233%
FOR NON VETERANS. THE PUBLIC
OFTEN ASSOCIATES TRAUMATIC
BRAIN INJURY AND POST TRAUMATIC
STRESS DISORDER WITH OUR- POST
NINE ELEVEN VETERANS HOWEVER
THE DEMAND FOR PST TREATMENT
HAS STEADILY INCREASED AS WELL
AMONG OUR VIETNAM VETERANS. AS
THEY AGE. CABS ALSO RECOGNIZES
BOTH ITS OBLIGATION AND THE
PRIVILEGED ADVOCATE FOR THE
VETERAN COMMUNITY FROM THE
GROUND UP. BY BRINGING EMERGING
IN THE COLLECTED ISSUES TO THE
ATTENTION OF POLICYMAKERS AND
THE LARGER COMMUNITY THREE SUCH
TOPICS OF MENTAL HEALTH
CONCERNS INCLUDE CALIFORNIA'S
ROLE BEDROOMS ARE EXPERIENCING
HIGHER OPIOID MISUSE. GROWING
HOMELESSNESS AND HIGH SUICIDE
RATES WE KNOW THAT OPIATE
ADDICTION CAN BE CAN TRITICUM
TRIBUTE TO FACTOR IN DEATH BY
SUICIDE THAT WE LACK ANY
SIGNIFICANT DATA HERE IN
CALIFORNIA THAT CAN HELP US
UNDERSTAND THE EXTENT OF THE
RELATIONSHIP. TELL NATIONAL
GUARD MANY OF WHOM ARE
VETERANS. WHO'S HOT HIGH
SUICIDE RATES THE RECENTLY COME
TO LIGHT AND WHOSE ACCESS TO VA
AND MENTAL HEALTH CARE IS VERY
IS VERY ABLE. CALIFORNIA
VETERANS- FAMILY CARE GIVERS
SUBJECT TO BURN OUT SECONDARY
POSTTRAUMATIC STRESS.
DEPRESSIVE DISORDERS AND LOWER
THAN AVERAGE RATES OF HEALTH
CARE AND- OF HEALTH INSURANCE
AND THIS IS PARTICULARLY
PROBLEMATIC SINCE VETERAN CARE
GIVERS AND THEIR FAMILIES ARE
REALLY OUR FIRST LINE OF
DEFENSE FOR VETERANS. ON
CHILDREN HOMELESSNESS AMONG
CALIFORNIA VETERANS REMAINS
HIGH. TEN THOUSAND EIGHT
HUNDRED HOMELESS PEOPLE
VETERANS IN CALIFORNIA SEVEN
THOUSAND OF WHOM ARE ON
SHELTERED 6667% DESPITE
CALIFORNIA'S MANY OF MANY
INNOVATIVE PROGRAMS AND
CONSIDERABLE ATTENTION TO
VETERANS HOUSING ISSUES
CALIFORNIA LEADS THE NATION
WITH THE GREATEST NUMBER OF ON
SHELTER HOMELESS VETERANS THIS
REPRESENTS A MAJOR CONCERN FOR
ALL CABS A MEMBER AGENCIES AND
CABS OVERALL BECAUSE A STATUS
CONFERS A MULTITUDE OF
PROBLEMS. THE INCREASING
PERCENTAGE OF ON SHELTERED
HOMELESS VETERANS OVERTIME
SIGNIFIES A MAJOR THREAT TO
MENTAL HEALTH AND PHYSICAL WELL
FOR VETERANS AND I WOULD ALSO
ADD- ASSEMBLY MEMBER WHEN YOUR
QUESTION ABOUT THE V. H. H. P.
PROGRAM THE SEVEN THOUSAND
CHILDREN VETERANS ARE THE
TARGETS FOR THE V. H. H. P.
PROGRAM AND THAT THAT WHILE THE
VETERAN POPULATION IS DECLINING
AT THAT POPULATION CONTINUES TO
GROW FOR SOME UNKNOWN REASON.
SO I'LL CLOSE BY NOTING THAT
THE TWENTY NINETEEN REPORT THAT
WE HAVE PREPARED WILL BE
DISTRIBUTED TO ALL YOUR
OFFICES- VIA EMAIL BEFORE THE
END OF FEBRUARY- WE LOOK
FORWARD TO FURTHER DISCUSSING
THE FINDINGS IN MORE DETAIL AND
AGAIN THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY. THANK YOU SO MUCH
NOW WILL OPEN UP TO QUESTIONS
FROM THE- SENATE MEMBERS
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS. YOUR OPEN FOR
THE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. GEN
ROBERT OF THANK YOU UP A QUICK
QUESTION YOU HAD INDICATED THAT
YOU THAT THE AND IT WAS THE
LITTLE HOOVER COMMISSION
SUGGESTED THAT THE- ACOSTA SAYS
WOULD NOT BE BASED ON INCOME
BUT ON COSTS OF CARE IS THAT IS
THAT ACCURATE- THAT'S CORRECT
YES AND WE DID NOT SPECIFY A
PARTICULAR FORMULA BUT WE
RECOMMEND TO THE COMMISSION
RECOMMENDED THAT THE STATE MOVE
FROM A PERCENTAGE OF INCOME TO
A TO SOME FORMULA BASED ON COST
OF CARE. BUT THE BUT THE
CURRENT FORM. IN THE- MILITARY
VETERAN US CODE RIGHT. ARM JUST
JUST A COMMENT THAT WOULD
TROUBLE ME GREATLY IF WE
BASICALLY SKEWED SERVICES TO
THOSE WHO ARE WEALTHIER VERSUS
THOSE WHO ARE NOT- STE. FOR
FUTURE CONSIDERATION OF. ALSO
WORKED WITH AND- AGAIN I
APOLOGIZE FOR BEING GONE FOR A
PORTION OF THE HEARING- I NOTE
FROM THE VARIOUS HOMES THAT ONE
OF THE- ISSUES THAT SEEMS TO BE
PREVALENT THROUGHOUT ALL THE
HOMES IS THE ABILITY TO
ATTRACT- EMPLOYEES WITH THE
NECESSARY SKILLS TO BE ABLE TO.
CARE FOR VETERANS IN THE WAY WE
EXPECT THEM TO BE CARED FOR- IT
HAD HAD ANY OF THE GROUPS LA-
OR ANY OTHERS- CONSIDERED
RECOMMENDING- SOME SORT OF COST
OF LIVING ADJUSTMENT. BASED ON
LOCALITY I MEAN WHAT WEST LA IS
GOT TO BE VERY DIFFERENT THAN
BARSTOW AND IF AND IF YOU HAVE
AND I MISSED IT I APOLOGIZE
BUT- JUST. MEDICARE OUT CITY. I
CAN SPEAK TO THAT- IN OUR
REPORT WE DID IDENTIFY THE
ISSUE OF HIRING A RETENTION AND
ONE OF OUR RECOMMENDATIONS IS
THAT THE LEGISLATURE. COULD
REQUIRE CALVET TO SUBMIT TO
REGULAR LEASE- WERE REGULARLY
DATA ON RECRUITMENT AND
RETENTION SO YOU COULD ASSESS
WHICH POSITIONS ARE REALLY THE
HARDEST TO HIGHER. INTEREST
THROUGH THAT- WITH THE THROUGH
THE ANNUAL BUDGET PROCESS AND
THEN CONSIDER- PROVIDING HOMES
WITH TARGETED RECRUITMENT AND
RETENTION FUNDING- FOR THOSE
HARDEST TO HIGHER POSITIONS.
ARE IN THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER. MITCHELL QUESTIONS OF
CENTER ROTH THEM THANK YOU FOR
HAVING THIS CHAIR WHEN YOU
SPEAK ABOUT COST OF CARE YOU
TALKING ABOUT. KAREN THE
SKILLED NURSING FACILITY OR YOU
TALKING ABOUT RESIDENCY IN THE
DUMBEST SO REPROGRAM- IT COULD
BE AGAIN THE COMMISSION DID NOT
SPECIFY A PARTICULAR FORMULAS
RED COULD BE ANY OF THOSE THE I
THINK THE THRUST OF THAT
RECOMMENDATION WAS ON ON
DOMICILIARY CARE ALTHOUGH THAT
WILL. IN OUR RESEARCH IT WILL
DECLINE OVER TIME LARGELY DUE
TO DEMAND BECAUSE OF IT MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT SKILLED
NURSING FACILITY. DEPENDING ON
YOUR OF VA DISABILITY RATE
THERE'S A- A REIMBURSEMENT THAT
FLOWS FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO THE STATE ON THAT
ONE AND CORRECT- AND I IT.
PERHAPS IF YOU HAVE SOME OTHER.
TYPE OF HEALTH INSURANCE
THERE'S SOME REIMBURSEMENT
THAT. FLOWS THERE AS WELL I
DON'T KNOW THAT ANSWER- THE
DUMBEST CELERY SITUATION WHERE
SOMEONE IS LIVING IN A ROOM. A
MY UNDERSTANDING IS THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT PROVIDES IS THE-
PAYMENT AND THEN WE CHARGE THE
RESIDENT BASED ON THEIR INCOME
FOR THE- RESIDENCY IN THAT
ROOM. SO BE INTERESTED
EXPLORING THAT AND THAT TIES IN
TO MY COMMENT WHICH IS THIS AYE
I WOULD HOPE THAT WE WOULD
CONTINUE TO. TAKE A LOOK AT THE
DUMBEST SO REPROGRAM THE
HISTORICALLY WE HAVE OPERATED
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO
ASSESS ITS CONTINUED VIABILITY
IN WHOLE OR IN PART OF
CERTAINLY WE HAVE AN OBLIGATION
IN MY VIEW AND I KNOW MY
COLLEAGUE SURE THIS TO TAKE
CARE OF OUR VETERANS
POPULATION. IF WE HAVE HOMELESS
VETERANS WE NEED TO FIND A
PLACE FOR THEM TO LIVE. IF WE
HAVE VETERANS WHO WERE NOT
HOMELESS WHO CHOOSE TO LIVE
THERE THAN I THINK WE NEED TO
MAKE A DECISION AS TO STEP
ESTAS STATE AS TO WHETHER TO.
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE HOUSING ON
ON THIS BASIS OR HOUSING ON
SOME OTHER BASIS WHETHER IT'S
IN THE FORM OF VOUCHERS OR
OTHERWISE. IN THE COMMERCIAL
MARKET PLACE ASSUMING. IN OUR
HOUSING MARKET THAT WE HAVE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA TODAY.
HOUSING EXISTS- FOR THE MONEY
THAT EITHER THE VETERANS HAVE
OR THAT WE'RE WILLING TO PAY
AND IF NOT WE NEED TO. PERHAPS
REVISIT THE CONTINUATION OF THE
DUMBEST SO RE PROGRAM. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR. THANK YOU US
ASSEMBLYMEMBER IF YOU HAD A
QUESTION AND THEY AYE SENATOR
AND THEN ASSEMBLYMAN- GLORIA
AYE AYE IS NAVY FOR AYE AYE. SO
ONE OF MY GREAT CONCERNS IS THE
FEMALE SUICIDE RATE FOR
VETERANS AND ALSO ACTIVE DUTY
BUT THAT'S NOT OUR PREVIEW. BUT
FOR VETERANS- MIGHT. NUMBERS
THAT I'M GETTING FROM THE
VETERANS OF FOREIGN WARS THE
AMERICAN LEGION AND DIFFERENT-
AND A TOTAL INFORMATION IS
FEMALE VETERANS HAVE A 22240%
HIGHER SUICIDE RATE THE MALE
VETERANS. EN GOOGLE IT BUT- I'M
NOT SEEING THE VETERANS
ADMINISTRATION AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL DO AND DEADLY ABOUT IT.
SO IS THERE ANYTHING THAT
CALIFORNIA CAN DO ABOUT IT
THAT'S MY QUESTION AND YOU
PROBABLY CAN'T ANSWER IT IT
WOULD HAVE TO BE ANSWERED UP
HERE BUT- WHAT WHAT I WOULD
WOULD ADD- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
VOCAL THAT THAT. YOUR
STATISTICS ARE RELATIVELY
ACCURATE CAN WE CERTAINLY
THERE'S A LOWER NUMBER OF
FEMALE VETERANS RIGHT NOW BUT A
HIGHER PERCENTAGE OF THOSE
FEMALE VETERANS HAVE. THEN
SUFFERED DEATH THROUGH SUICIDE-
WE HAVE- AT CABS IS AGENCIES
ARE TRYING TO START SEPARATE
PROGRAMS THAT ARE FOCUSED ON
WOMEN VETERANS AND THEIR
FAMILIES AND SO NOT ONLY IS A
SUICIDE RATE A PROBLEM- THE
GENERAL CARE- AND MODIFYING OUR
FACILITIES TO CARE FOR WOMEN
VETERANS IS ALSO ANOTHER LARGE
PROBLEM FOR US. THANK ASSEMBLY
GLORIA FAMOUS CHAIR THANK YOU
TO THE PRESENTERS- I THINK I
KNOW THE ANSWER THIS QUESTION
BUT THAT WAS WORTH ASKING BASED
ON THE MASTER PLAN THERE'S A
SERIES OF PROJECTIONS ARE
ESTIMATES- AS THE SECRETARY
INDICATED BAHRAIN YOU KNOW
SIGNIFICANT NATIONAL CONFLICT
OR NATIONAL CONFLICTS. AT DO
YOU ARE YOU ARE COMFORTABLE
WITH THE PROJECTIONS THE
METHODOLOGY THEY USED TO
PROJECT POPULATION NEED- IN
CALIFORNIA. TO A TO A I WOULD
SAY FOR BUT GENERALLY SPEAKING
YES BUT I WOULD- ECHOED JACQUI
EARLIER COMMENT THAT THE- THREE
HUNDRED PAGE DOCUMENT AND WOOD
WE'RE STILL LOOKING AT IT WELL
TO. ROSS IS STILL LOOKING AT IT
BUT JUST BASED OFF OF THEIR
COMMENTS TODAY THE
ACKNOWLEDGEMENT THAT SOME OF IT
MAY BE NATIONAL AND NOT
SPECIFIC TO CALIFORNIA THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT. WE WOULD- LOOK
AT TO SEE HOW A PLUGGABLE IT IS
THEN TO THE CALIFORNIA CONTACT.
AND I RECOGNIZE IS EXTREMELY
DIFFICULT TO. FOR YES HUMAN.
BEHAVIOR ETCETERA ETCETERA BUT
AS WE TRY PLAN FOR NEED- HE
DOES FOR TO SEE. THE
ADJUSTMENTS I THINK WITH
SECRETARY SAID THAT WE'RE NOW
NUMBER NUMBER TO THE STATE-
INTO THE VETERAN POPULATION
WHICH IS. DISCONCERTING I'VE
BEEN A SAN DIEGANS- ALTHOUGH
I'M GLAD TO SEE THE ROLE THAT
SAN DIEGO WILL CONTINUE TO
PLAY. A PROMINENT LONER
CLIFORNIA VETERAN COMMUNITY-
SO IF YOU ARE COMFORTABLE WITH
THE- PROJECTIONS I GUESS ONE OF
THINGS THAT TOOK AWAY FOR THE
MASTER PLAN AND THE
CONVERSATION WE'VE HAD ON THE
VETERANS COMMITTEE LAST NUMBER
OF YEARS. IS THE PLACEMENT OF
THE HOMES- OR THE SERVICES THAT
WE PROVIDE AND HOW. DICE A
RADICAL OUT OF WHACK THEY ARE
COMPARED TO NEED. I'M SO HENCE
THE PROJECTIONS. NEED
UNDERSTAND IT THAT'S
BENEFICIAL. OR OR OR OR OR
RIGHT IN I RECOGNIZE LAW THAT'S
ACADEMIC GIVEN THAT WE DON'T
MEET ALL THE DEMAND- THAT'S OUT
THERE- BUT- I GUESS THE
QUESTION FILIOQUE SHOULD POSE
SOME QUESTIONS THAT WE OUGHT TO
ASK GOING FORWARD. WHAT WILL
HAS THE ASSEMBLY OR THE
LEGISLAURE ASH SAY. PLATED AND
PASSED LOCATION OF VETERANS
HOME A CO BECAUSE THAT IS IN
VOTING FOR. VETERAN HOME BONDS
BUT I DON'T. RECALL THAT BEING
SPECIFIC TO WHERE WE GOT TO
PLACE IT. I KNOW THERE'S THE
VETOES FIVE RULES NOW SERVE
THEY DON'T KNOW HOPEFULLY THAT
WOULD IN. THERE WITH THE
MISTAKES WILL BE MADE GOING FOR
BUT- IS THERE LEGISLATIVE.
REQUIREMENT BEFORE THE A HOME
IS CITED OR IF THAT. WOULD AYE
AYE MAGICAL CLOSURE WAS
REQUIRED WOULD HAVE TO HAVE WE
ARE. WEIGH IN ON THAT- BUT
FUTURE SIGHTING OF HOMES IS
THAT SOMETHING THAT WE GET TO
DO IS AS SOON AS DECIDED BY
OTHERS. I MEAN IT TIES TO ON
THE QUESTIONS THAT RE RAISED IS
HOW WILL THE DECISION MAKING
PROCESS OF IMPLEMENTING THE
FINDINGS AND RECOMMENDATIONS OF
THIS MASTER PLAN ACTUALLY
ROLLOUT BUT JUST IN OUR PRIOR
EXPERIENCE MOST RECENTLY. THE
PROPOSAL TO. CONSTRUCT A- NEW
REPLACEMENT SKILLED NURSING
FACILITY WITHIN YACHT BILL. IT
SEEMS LIKE SOMETHING OF THAT
SORT WOULD HAVE TO GO THROUGH
THE BUDGET PROCESS SO THAT'S
WHERE THE LEGISLATURE COULD.
CONNECT BUT- IS THERE A WAY IN
WHICH THE LEGISLATURE COULD
PROVIDE. INSIGHTS FEED ACT
THEIR PRIORITY WHAT THEIR
THOUGHTS ARE BEFORE IT GETS TO
THAT LEVEL AND THAT'S A- A
QUESTION OF. THE PROCESS OF.
HOW WILL THESE RECOMMENDATIONS
BE MOVING AND WHERE WILL THE
LEGISLATURE NOT WHAT STAGE WITH
THE LEGISLATURE BEING GAUGED. I
BELIEVE THE MASTER PLAN
REQUIRED BE UPDATED WITH SOME
REGULARITY CRACK. EVERY FIVE
YEARS- SO THEORETICALLY THERE'S
A THERE'S A HOOK IN THERE FOR
US TO BE ABLE TO WAY AND IF WE
START TO SEE. A HOME BEING
ABOUT HOW. IN LOVE DESERT. IN
THEIR HEAD AND NECK COMMISERATE
FULL ENOUGH VENTURE OUT TO A
DESERT WE BE ABLE HAVE SOME
WAITED FLUENCE THAT PROCESS.
YES AND IT SALAS. ABOUT GETTING
TO CENTER ON BIRDS. QUESTION
ABOUT RELOCATION. IF THAT'S-
THAT YOU WOULD ALSO WANT TO SEE
IN FUTURE RATIONS OF WHAT WHAT.
OF LOCATION. LOOK LIKE. THOSE
THINGS THAT COULD BE. I'M
EXPLORED I JUST I REMARK ON
THIS OR LOOK AT BECAUSE IT'S
BEEN A HEAD SCRATCH. IN THE- OF
OUR HOUSING. GENERAL ARE HOME
DESCRIBES WAS. AND THE NUMBER
OF ACTION OF OVER. IN BOTH AND-
TO THE EXTENT ANY ON YOU TO.
CAPACITY IN THE SYSTEM YOU KNOW
WE SHOULD ALL BE EMBARRASSED BY
THAT AND WE SHOULD BE DOING
WHAT WE CAN TO FIX IT I
RECOGNIZE THE MASTER PLAN TO
STEP IN THAT DIRECTION. I
BELIEVE THE AGENCY AND
DEPARTMENT ARE COMMITTED TO
WORKING ON THAT. BUT SOME OF US
JUST GEOGRAPHY- IF THAT'S THE
CASE- DEAL ME IN ON TRIED
INFLUENCE HOW THIS COMES OUT-
VETOES FIVE WILL BE BECOME. YOU
KNOW STATE LAW OR SOMETHING
LIKE THAT BUT- BUT- YOU YOU GET
MY POINT ABOUT. THE YOU KNOW
IT'S FIVE THE PERSONALITIES THE
ALIGNMENT CHECK AROUND THE
STABLES ALL BODY ON THIS BUT
WHO'S TO SAY. TERMINATES
ADMINISTRATIONS BEING WHAT THEY
ARE. THAT THE COMMON SENSE WILL
PREVAIL ON THAT WE DON'T BILL
THAT HOME OUT IN ILLINOIS WHERE
YOU GET MY POINT BUT- SOMEONE
ASKED TO. HEAR DIRECTLY FROM
THE PUBLIC ON WHAT THE STATE IS
DOING CORRECTLY NOT CORRECTLY.
I'LL MAKE SURE THAT WE DO MORE
THAT WE CAN- AND AGAIN THAT
NEED. AND ON UTILIZED CAPACITY
IS SOMETHING THAT ALL OF US
SHOULD BE WORKING. I CAN'T TO
FIX. STILL IN THE- CHAIR.
NORTHERN IRAQ. I'M GONNA TURN
IT OVER THE SENATE. WHEN FOR
THE PUBLIC COMMON AND CLOSING.
ASIDE AS- FIRST ONE THANK BOTH
OF OUR PANELS. AND I DO WANT
TO. ESPECIALLY THANK THE LITTLE
HOOVER COMMISSION WHO TOOK THIS
ISSUE ON A NUMBER OF YEARS AND-
AND IT WAS A VERY THOROUGH
REPORT AND- AND YOU CAN SAY IT
SEE THAT MANY OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS WERE. IF NOT
MOST OF THE RECOMMENDATIONS
WERE TAKEN SO WE APPRECIATE THE
WORK YOU DID. THAT THREE OR
FOUR YEARS AGO. AND ALLEN DIED
THANK YOU TOO AGAIN FOR A VERY
INFORMATIVE AN- UPDATE WE
APPRECIATE IT. AND NOW WE HAVE
A PUBLIC COMMENT. IN. AND
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME AND WHO
YOU ARE REPRESENTING. THE STATE
AND LOCAL AND WITH. ASIAN
AMERICANS. THIS WORK. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS DANA
NICKEL THAT WITH READ
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS OF MOST OF
THE POINTS I WANT TO COVER HAVE
ALREADY BEEN TALKED ABOUT IN
LENGTH TODAY SO THANK YOU ARE
VETERANS SERVICE ORGANIZATION
CLIENTS FOR STILL STUDYING THE
MASTER PLAN IT WILL GO TO BE
GOING OVER IT WITH HER MEMBERS
THE SUMMER. THE SECRETARY ABLY
COVERED THE NATURE OF MODERN
WARFARE QUITE WELL. THERE MAY
BE LESS VETERANS OVERALL BUT
MORE OF THEM WILL NEED OUR HELP.
OUR KNOWLEDGE AND AWARENESS OF
THE INJURIES THAT ARISE FROM
MILITARY SERVICE HAS GROWN WE
NOW UNDERSTAND I RECOGNIZE PTSD
TRAUMATIC BRAIN INJURY MILITARY
SEXUAL TRAUMA SUBSTANCE ABUSE
DISORDERS AND THE FACTORS OF CO
MORBIDITY. THIS STATION WILL
UNDOUBTEDLY FACE FUTURE
CONFLICTS SO WE MUST STAND
READY TO ASSIST ASSIST. THE MEN
AND WOMEN WHO HAVE SERVED US.
REGARDING THE SECRETARY'S
OBSERVATION THAT WE WILL NEVER
HEALTH ALL THE BEDS WE NEED.
THE COUNTY VETERANS SERVICE
OFFICERS VETERANS SERVICE
PROVIDERS AND OTHER
PROFESSIONALS WHO STRIVE TO
HELP VETERANS BEFORE PROBLEMS
MANIFEST TO A LARGER PROBLEM
DOWN THE ROAD. CAN REDUCE THE
IMPACT ON THE VET HOME SYSTEM.
AN OUNCE OF PREVENTION IS WORTH
A POUND OF CURE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT IT. FOR
SEVEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS DAVE TELL- THANK YOU FOR
TAKING MY COMMENTS I GUESS I'M
THE COUNTY VETERANS SERVICE
OFFICER OVER IN SANTA CLARA
COUNTY AND WAS UP IN THE AREA
HERE FOR SOME TRAINING WITH
TRACY AND- WE'RE JUST THAT
CALVET LEARNING AND GETTING
ACCREDITED THROUGH THE STATE
JUST WANTED TO COME OVER AND
SAY HI AND LET YOU KNOW THAT
WE'RE HERE LISTENING AND HERE
TO HELP. SOME THANK YOU VERY
WELCOME THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
WELL- IT LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE NO
MORE SPEAKER SO I WANT TO THANK
ALL THE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS AND
SENATORS THAT- JOINED US TODAY
AND I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO THANK
MY COACH HERE. SENATOR HART'S
LETTO AND- AGAIN APPRECIATE ALL
THE WORK THAT WENT INTO THE
REPORT AND THE COMMENTS AFTER.
THIS MEETING IS ADJOURNED.
SENATOR BOB WORKS BEST.